so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody dopaziola here
thomas whatever you want to call me i am
here with marty o'neal what's up folks
what's up guys today you are back on
another episode of the dope as usual
podcast we're here to talk about life
drugs accomplishments problems and
everything in between today we have a
very very big fan requested guest this
is larry lawton this is the larry lawton
episode thank you for being here i'm
really happy to be here thomas thank you
for being here the first question the
first thing i am going to say i usually
don't do this
but just in case everybody's like larry
lawton why have i seen that face please
explain
real quick in a nutshell what do you do
now well we'll get into the before what
do you do right now right now i have a
pod uh youtube channel that's called
larry laurent jewel thief now i was the
biggest jewel robber in the country
we'll get into that in a little bit but
i started a youtube channel a little
over two years ago
it blew up because i'm the real deal yes
and i tell it like it is the what
clicked on my youtube channel
is i have the number one
watched playlist gangster redemption
series
and it's my actual book which we have
will show it's my book that i narrate
online and people just wow is this real
of course it's been fact checked the
thousand times it's 100 real and that's
what's so easy for me to come on your
show
you can ask me i don't give a [ __ ] ask
me anything you want and i'm an open
book and i think that's the way we
should but i do want to say thanks again
for having me i love your show i've been
watching it before i go on shows and i
love the way you guys hang his party and
stuff and we're going to get into all of
this in a bit well yeah thank you for
being here marty and i so the how i
found you it's like two in the morning
i'm high [ __ ] my girlfriend's asleep
like all right she's asleep i'm watching
whatever the [ __ ] we're watching and
then i see a picture of you
and he goes
prison [ __ ]
i love stories man that's my thing i
love telling stories i started it two
seconds and i go oh this guy's a real
prisoner i can tell i grew up with a lot
of
inmates around me so i know i'm like oh
okay let's watch this i watched about
three minutes in
the next morning i woke up text our
booking age mike there's a person named
larry lawton on youtube please book this
person right now and that was it i've
been watching
i won't say i've only watched about four
because i don't wanna like i said i
don't wanna learn everything about you
and then come here go oh really oh i
knew that already so i wanna learn as
the audience learns today and that's
great it's funny because i i was just at
carrillo as a friend and and we had a
big party and he ended up doing the same
thing and he says larry i fell down
you're a rabbit hole yeah i watched six
hours of your videos i couldn't get off
the videos and then we were at a party
and it was really i gotta thank him too
it was a great party but this is this is
like you know when i come on the podcast
and i've been around the tv i do a lot
of national tv all that kind of stuff
i like your podcast just because the way
it's done it's real it's like i do my
podcast now which we started called the
real deal with larry lawton it's blowing
up now when did you start that oh
six months ago if that and that's
blowing up because we do it where
there's no cut no [ __ ] no edit you say
it i tell people you come on you better
be
you [ __ ] up the world's gonna know about
it you know and i like that part of it
and i think that's the catch for us you
have it obviously great setup thanks for
the whole you know the hospitality and
everything you're professional and i
love coming on and now i'm an open book
and that's what i i think we're going to
have fun today the best thing about
being real is you never have to
backtrack and go what did i tell that
person
i could never live like that we talk
about this a lot i would never be able
to sleep
or live like that you know people say to
me oh i heard that story ten years ago
well it's a real story i don't say it
because it's me you wanna know about how
to hide a knife up your ass i'm going to
tell you
but that's going to happen this show is
going to get wild but it's you know it's
because it's not made up it's not real i
lived that i was in the joint for a
really long time tortured views we're
going to get into a lot of things
and i i think it opens people's eyes
because the message too
is
you can make bad choices we could turn
around and become a success
always and that is what i think most
people know from doing every drug
robbing mob [ __ ] i mean i was the gamut
and then you could come out on the other
side
you know for the right reasons and
especially with me you know i went away
when my daughter was 15 months old and
my son was just turned seven two days
and i and i didn't get out until my son
was 18.
my daughter was 13.
so i had a a tough
all my own fault i'll never try to tell
anybody oh me that that that [ __ ] don't
cut it things happen for reasons or
whatever they are and now i'm here and
you know
we're going to be on a podcast and i
know you reach a lot of guys who party
and we all we're going to smoke we're
going to have a good time
and but you can do that and still be
responsible you could still have fun you
can still live your life and i think
that's important for a lot of people to
know i love that you started off with
that that's what me and marty preach
like i can do everything i do i can
smoke a joint too
it's fine as long as you're responsible
you get your [ __ ] done because once it
becomes
the responsibility on the back end
that's when you start seeing your
friends go to jail and seeing people
[ __ ] up my my saying in all of stuff and
you're gonna like this you can use it
you control it don't let it control you
and that could be anything that could be
gambling that could be food that could
be pot
drugs anything i'm a proponent of
letting people make choices now if you
do drugs and you go rob for those drugs
now you're going to be held accountable
yeah but if you're at your house you
want to do whatever i don't give a [ __ ]
what you do i mean but be responsible
you control it
don't let it control you put the it and
fill in whatever you want exactly that's
the it is blank the it is the blank you
control pot
don't let pot control you yeah it's true
i don't know it's harmless but i've seen
[ __ ] throw their lives away
just smoking weed not doing [ __ ]
you know
listen
you make a funny statement i've done
every drug in the book
when i do weed i'm usually lay down i
want to [ __ ] i used to get this is
true story i used to send a guy work for
me junior
and i said i'm starting to smoke now i
wasn't a big smoker i parted everything
coke
acid [ __ ] speed anything you wanted
and i never again i always controlled it
never had the addictive personality but
when i smoked weed
i used to tell him go to the store get
junk he'd bring back the pringles you
know [ __ ] pringles i'm a big [ __ ]
guy i'd be laying in my chair [ __ ]
pringles here i'm [ __ ] smoking i got
the bong over here i'm smoking back then
this is now in the 90s early 90s i'm
smoking crippy crippy was the crypt
crippy was the big deal you know all
purple haze all this [ __ ] no [ __ ]
i'm [ __ ] i'm so [ __ ] up that drug
if i would have kept at that level
would have [ __ ] me up
more than any other drug even today i
smoke i enjoy it i love it in florida we
have a medical marijuana card so i have
one of course and i smoke and i and i
love it and i'd love to mellow
especially after i do things
you know here we're gonna have fun this
is your show they said dad you pause i'm
in whatever we do we're gonna have fun
with them you know
thomas is is like that and you you let
your guests be them exactly and that's
what i i like about it i'm [ __ ]
excited this is the very start of the
first five minutes i'm glad you're
watching about the show this is that
show yeah this is the perfect show
people come on and get into the
nitty-gritty of their lives just start
talking sure like it's
the biggest conversation the deepest
conversation when you're just hanging
out with your friends in the [ __ ]
garage not doing anything and this is
basically a garage with really nice
lights
you just said it you know i started my
podcast the real deal
with larry lawton and i have a co-host
and and
this guy ben's and we get guys and we
have characters now we have a [ __ ]
character it's called meth head mic
listen to this this is how it stirs [ __ ]
and we didn't plan it
the guy is living in his parents house
he's 34 his parents live in italy he has
a roommate his roommate is getting a
fight you know the girl he calls the
cops he's sitting in his recliner next
to him is a plate of meth he invites the
cops in what do you do they arrest them
for [ __ ] meth
meth head mike talk about [ __ ] out
there
wow we're gonna have to send a picture
and it it it's just it's great because
it's so real this [ __ ] is [ __ ] real
yes he's one about he's one of our
characters now thomas and this guy is
[ __ ] we i mean we asked him we ended
one show when he talked about
have you ever been with a [ __ ] well
i'll tell that story hold that for the
next [ __ ] bobcats and he's the kind
of guy that comes on in but we're gonna
do these two and i'm explaining yeah
we're gonna do everything man today oh
look at this man that's you do i get my
own in this show oh for sure oh man this
is gonna really [ __ ] me up you could
just we got nothing left guys do we my
team we had nothing left today i can
smoke this
all right all right
so yeah feel free to just let that [ __ ]
last an hour let me just last an hour
don't don't feel like you need to right
right no no we're good conversation
joints
gentlemen oh they are they are you know
you have a lot of fun
and to let you know right now even
before we start to your audience i'm an
open book
you can ask me any questions
i have something and believe me you're
going to get an answer so here's my
background not not something that has a
statue of limitation only kidding
i knew before i'm like no he's fine
because one thing i do before for
certain guys like hey please don't
incriminate yourself and if you do
please let us know when you did it and
we'll [ __ ] cut it out
just in case because there has been a
few times ago
yeah
well you do know i did the law for 10
years i'm a licensed paralegal did law
for 10 years helped people get out of
prison
pretty much an expert on federal law i
did that and believe me i know that and
then not only do my lawyers tell me that
i know it myself okay so you already
know what's going on oh yeah this is
this is good weed right here you ready
so my quick quick tiny quick background
so you know i'm like why are you asking
these crazy ass questions
i'm obviously brown but my mom is looks
like a white lady she's jewish and
mexican right she married my stepdad a
long time ago he was
an aryan member type of thing i used to
go to a corporate a lot visited he was
an aryan for real like uh whether it's a
dirty white boy or uh you already know
what's up
in california like all the bolts and the
vikings absolutely down you know yeah
yeah so when i used to go to visit him
it'd be weird we'll get into it later
because i can't really talk about all of
it but he's a stabby kind of guy you
already know what i'm talking about so
so that's why i know so much because i
grew up with this [ __ ] guy and these
hell's angel fools at her house i'm like
uh i'm brown get these for the [ __ ] out
of here this isn't a good look for me my
sister man my mom passes but not me so
if i asked a certain question like why
do you know this this is what i know
this listen i never underestimate first
of all a host i've been on
uh you're not a rookie at this either so
it's not like you're doing this first
two months yeah you you know your [ __ ]
you and you i'm sure you do your
research like i do and everybody else
and watch the guys videos or do
something to know who they are so i
don't trust me i won't even want to know
maybe how you want to know that end i
got you i got you okay so
for everyone out here let's get [ __ ]
started i'm ready all right i'm ready
let's break it down from right here
let's start from i read a little but i
just wanted to touch on it you were in
that says the navy or the p uh what was
it the u.s
coast guard postcard sorry coast guard i
always mix that up
how did you go from the coast guard to
doing what you're doing but let's just
do it chronologically you're you're a
person you're an upstanding person you
go to the coast guard you're doing your
thing what makes you leave that life
onto your next chapter well let's back
it up even a hair more go for it uh no i
wasn't an upstanding guy joining the
coast guard i was a troublemaker i mean
i started crime at 11 12 years old doing
football tickets when i say doing
football tickets is a gambling ticket
the mob got i would pass them out to the
whole neighborhood and you would get you
take a t you put a dollar on it and you
pick three teams you win five dollars
you pick four teams you win ten dollars
they call football tickets so i'm now in
1972
and i'm making a hundred twenty-five
dollars a week whoa
72 as a [ __ ] 12 year old kid
and i was making this money because
every dollar you bring in to the bookie
that are bigger bookies
you get 25 and you hope you win i want
you to win cause you're gonna tip me you
know oh you pick five teams you get
twenty dollars so you put five dollars
down you get a hundred dollars for
victony's team you throw the kid five
dollars who did the ticket yeah he comes
to your house you might be a a bus
driver a school teacher or uh you know
electrical worker
in the neighborhood working i grew up in
a a working
italian
kind of neighborhood you know my next
door neighbor is a maid guy mobster
guy down a corner street i mean what
street what city in the bronx new york
that's where i actually that's i grew up
and then after the service but at 17.
now we did all [ __ ] when we were kids
rob cars take him to [ __ ] uh chop
shops get 500 a car we did a lot of
crazy [ __ ]
so let's just say we come from the
streets you know this is this is not no
i i i was i guess i was a good kid you
know you were you were shooting killing
everybody so you're a good kid you're
just making money yeah
exactly yeah and you know i was this
little kid you see me as i'm 240 pounds
a pretty big guy all this [ __ ] i was a
little i went in the coast guard in 1979
i was 17 just turning 18. i just [ __ ]
aged myself for your whole audience you
know because i'm born in 1961.
so when i went in i was 132 pounds
blonde hair
wiry [ __ ] kid but a street kid knew
the game you know knew all the [ __ ] that
that that goes on in it so when i went
in the coast guard in 1979 i go through
boot camp i become i start getting
better but i ended up becoming a boat
captain a rescue boats i was rescue
people i was on three major
disasters in the coast i was on a free
to flotilla with the cubans
in 1981 you ever watched scarface what
the movie i was the one picking the
people up in key west
and matter of fact it's all in the book
too it really is [ __ ] wild stuff and
i was a kid and i'm out there in 1981
and it went into 82 and i'm in key west
called the navy moles where the
headquarters were all the cube i have a
big heart for cubans and people always
ask why i said listen i watched people
come in here on an inner tube to get
away now how [ __ ] up was it over there
yes so my thing was i'm the kind of guy
listen like i always say in my old
business i never heard anybody wasn't in
my business
now if you were in our business you
weren't paying your tax you're doing you
you didn't want to run across me from
laying guys arms on curbs and snapping
them and i was that kind of bad guy but
again i'm never proud of that it is just
who i am we all grow up the way we grow
up
and at 17 i go in so i'm in there i get
hurt in the service
i hurt my back very severely i get
retired disability from the united
states coast guard what age i was 26. oh
[ __ ] that bad yeah i got retired i still
have it to this day
luckily i've had major operations and
all that kind of [ __ ]
so i'm all right i'm doing great you
know i get out but i get right back into
the business i go move in with my
brother who's in brooklyn
and brooklyn is the mecca for mobsters
if you want to call so we had people and
they knew my reputation as a kid i used
to send
[ __ ] paint and [ __ ] when i got higher
up in the coast guard i used to go to
the exchanges buy [ __ ] and send it to
brooklyn
[ __ ] you know rope and paint and [ __ ]
they [ __ ] selling it it's hot [ __ ]
you know they're [ __ ] crazy back then
they didn't have track and [ __ ] and all
the crap you know you send it you have
the invoice for that and they tell you
you're in the in the military and they
say to you hey listen the budget's up
you got to go spend 30 000 go to the
[ __ ] exchange
it's like a big warehouse for navy where
we shop coast guard navy all the the
military and it'd be paint and ropes and
lines and but anything you [ __ ] want
i would start getting [ __ ] and then i
would ship it
to [ __ ] brooklyn
yeah you guys selling it well what the
[ __ ] yeah i got some great stories about
the coast guard that with pot but anyway
then we go i get out in
1986 i'm retired i was in almost eight
years 1986 and december 30 first 80. you
weren't around yet not yet now yeah you
were getting there
the milk was in the cow that got you
[ __ ] [ __ ] so
that's where we're at
it's a nice great appointment
yeah we're past it's not even in your
father's balls yet it's [ __ ] still in
the cow my dad's in 10th grade i think
yeah
exactly probably
but anyway so we go
and i get out and i start bartending i
was taken by the mobsters
and put in a place in queens in its
luke's piano lounge it was a mobster bar
matter of fact there was a jewish bookie
i learned from who's with one of the
biggest bookies in all of new york he's
what they call a layoff guy
meaning if you have a hundred thousand
dollars on one team
and a hundred thousand on the other you
make ten percent that's the vig
that's that's how gambling works
now if you have a hundred thousand on
this team they're playing the giants
playing the jets i don't give a [ __ ] you
got a hundred 000 on this team and 50 on
this team you're not no more a bookie
you're a gambler you're hoping this team
wins yeah so you got to take that 50 000
and bring it up so you're you're 50 50.
that's your game is a good bookie
because you're making ten percent
taking a million dollars on one two
million another
nice hundred grand you're bad not a bad
[ __ ] day's work huh yeah well this
guy mack i work for and i learned the
business from
was the biggest in new york he used to
take the layoff action from the regular
bookies
so the guy would come in say mac i need
to put 70 000 on this he would you know
negotiate the line that guy needs so
it's a 50 50 split so stressful no no
actually you know i got to know the
business so well
obviously then
i'm in new york
and i'm doing and i also muscled a card
game that was underneath in the cellars
in new york so i did that then i come
back to uh now i'm in brooklyn in
i don't know you if you know the area at
all brooklyn king's highway west 10th
street if you're nerdy
work you know that i'm from buffalo
might as well be a different one oh well
that's not new york i don't know
from jersey more new york than him oh
yeah for sure i mean because oh really
yeah oh yeah yeah i don't know any of
these costs they've never been never
been easy okay you're gonna have to come
sometime you know i'm in florida so
you're gonna have to do that i'm going
to floor soon
you're going to go to florida when you
do you definitely have to come see oh
yeah you already know what's up over
there yo definitely so then i ended up
doing that and then
one of my guys i was like the robber the
muscle for the guy i mean heists this we
used to hijack trucks we used to do a
whole bunch of [ __ ] in new york so can i
ask you before we move on absolutely in
your head
when you're robbing somebody and are
they in the business that you guys are
talking about is that what you're saying
i don't rob i don't mess with people
that aren't in my business is that no no
they could well
a lot of the robbers were set ups
you know the truck driver calls i got a
load of this [ __ ] we ended up they talk
about smart back when i was around they
started putting gps in the trucks
but not like they do like you know
lojack and the [ __ ] they had they would
put a box if they had a whole 18 wheeler
full of vcrs
wow my [ __ ] date myself so vcrs so
they would put a tracking device in one
of those boxes well we got to the girl
and the officer told us oh it's in this
box in the left corner because they they
have it where it is so they don't keep
losing it when they unload a box they
got to take that out put it somewhere
give it back to the next truck
we would find out where that box was
we'd hijack the truck go along the
highway
the bqe and take it and stop and put the
box right on the side of the road and go
empty now they think that their truck is
stopped
stuck there in traffic there
so you beat any system you want yes i
don't care who you are you can beat it
gotcha and look at me i'm teaching
people a lot of [ __ ] on this show right
you're learning okay it's okay if
they're willing to steal vcrs go for it
get those off i want to see what he gets
for vcu where are you going to get those
off the 90s are in that's what my goal
90s already says
um so you're in new york you're doing
your uh you're doing your thing you
start the business with the guy max he
shows you how to do that i didn't start
the business his business i'm working
i'm learning and stuff okay i ain't
starting
these are the big [ __ ] guys i'm just
learning working for business
i understood book making and understood
numbers i was good about that and i
learned and i was you know i learned a
couple of things that you you you shut
up you listen and you gain so much
knowledge when you're around a lot of
people i used to play cards with the
boss then it was a captain
and i'd play cards and other guys and
i'm just sitting there now i'm in my 30s
now
uh i'm robbing stores my first robbery
was actually a setup
was an actual [ __ ] setup
of uh
to rob a jewelry store for insurance
money
oh my end was 150 k
damn not bad [ __ ] back then either
yeah
250 right now
and we did that but i said wait a minute
i could do this [ __ ] without a setup and
i did become the biggest jewel robber in
the united states ever and robbed
between 15 and 18 million and
20-something stores all over the east
coast are you just walking in the front
[ __ ] door and robbing them no it's
you don't just walk in the front door
this is like how does this is in l.a
today you know this is it no
am i right or wrong come on guys you got
to be right it's true it's [ __ ] true
it's wild listen i did my research [ __ ]
this no i like that out here [ __ ] this
no i'm liking it out here
out here right now i really i'm liking
it so what but what i was getting at is
you you have to take time you case the
store it could take a week two weeks
your case thousands of stores you got to
know what's in there where you know
there's an art to robbery it's not you
know the smash and grab guys and that
you heard of those guys go in they grab
you know tray roll x's and run
those are rookies you know you can
prevent that they have buzzes on doors
or whole [ __ ] none of that [ __ ] stopped
the professional because when i wanted
your store and if i thought it was right
you're getting hit
now that wasn't a setup so what i meant
by not [ __ ] with now even with the
people i robbed
never hit them never beat them never
matter of fact i would never put a gag
in them because i was always worried
about them choking
i don't want nobody to die
yeah you know
they shut up trust me you've got a gun
in your face and you get you're down
you're tied up and i tell you to look at
that wall don't [ __ ] turn around what
are you gonna do yeah you're not [ __ ]
turning around trust me i haven't seen
someone say oh [ __ ] you
nah that didn't work
so you're robbing these stores and you
said the first one that wasn't a set it
was a setup and he said i can do this by
myself yeah
so that spark that motivated you this is
too [ __ ] easy to do this without you
guys you notice the difference you know
when i grew up
kids
you know i hate to say things are over
or different when i grew up you had a
hustle you had a show to people big
people you're smart you had a way to
make money uh yeah they're gonna help
you they're gonna give you things like
uh okay here's a spot go get that we can
do this over here
but they love to see in innovative
people you know people who loud they
have the the brains and the wherewithal
how to get to a robbery or make a
whatever or doing trucks i mean there's
so many robbers we did warehouses
[ __ ] your cat i mean i'll get into
how you get a guy in the hook and then
you got the warehouse manager opening a
[ __ ] door for you on a sunday
you know taking the whole [ __ ] store
yeah and you already got it out because
you already talked about hey listen i
got a warehouse all this plumbing
supplies you want them you bring up
everything i got it because he owns a
construction company he's building
schools now i'm telling i'm stealing the
[ __ ] toilets the [ __ ] thing matter
of fact my house i had said i've had all
gold forces of course you know they come
off with me so they're all [ __ ] god
all this [ __ ] the jacuzzis and all that
so we would get a ride or rent the truck
23 foot rider rent the truck after we
got to the man the guy who owns the
the manager of the warehouse this is
mega
the warehouse is big as a walmart you
know i mean they're huge these are where
they're not rubbing the whole thing no
they never knew they were robbed
because there's such an inventory and
the guy who's running the warehouse is
the one that [ __ ] lets us in because
we get him
[ __ ] he's in daddy's a gambler all of
a sudden the guy owes [ __ ] three
granny can't pay he's a regular guy
can't pay the three grand
all right now even though i own the sh
the loan shark
i say listen you better [ __ ] pay my
three grand oh my what am i gonna do
go to see this guy fat tommy i know he's
going to lend you the money and you got
to pay him his interest or whatever you
do and then you and then you're good
with me it's all me
listen it's all me
now he goes to this guy and he goes
listen
i'll lend you the three grand but it's
three points now points work every week
so if i lent you a thousand dollars
you'd have to give me 30 every friday
until you give me the thousand back
so you say i only need it for a while my
taxes are coming in here's a thousand
30 this week 30 this week 30 this week
and [ __ ] uh
uh at the end of the day you give me my
thousand we're all cool but a lot of
times you don't want to give that
thousand somethings happen that's when
you get into and debt he's still
gambling he's trying to pay back and now
the guy owes more money
and this guy goes hey listen he called
me this [ __ ] guy said he's gonna
break your [ __ ] legs you better give
him his phone what do i do let me talk
to him i know the guy
so now this happens it's me
i talked to the guy i said here's what
he said he goes listen to me
i can help you out i'ma get you to clear
your debt
but he you know you're working the way
out you know the guy by now he's
gambling you work in this warehouse is
there any way we can send some guys you
don't have to be involved
oh real listen you'll clear your debt
and make a few dollars
now the guy's got a five thousand dollar
debt he's [ __ ] saying oh okay
figuring out how to do he doesn't get
caught these places out there the size
of a warehouse i mean you know mega the
forklifts all this [ __ ]
he's running a warehouse you know how
much [ __ ] product gets lost every
year yeah obviously and you're taking
gold forces you're taking [ __ ] copper
wire that was big
so we do all that and then
the guy comes we take it we go in there
sent the guys ride or rent the truck
boom boom he comes back to give the guy
five thousand he just sold the whole
truck for 75 000
so you give this now this guy's happy
[ __ ] he's thinking i got a way out every
time i [ __ ] up
i mean but you got to be careful cause
then he gets caught and he squeals on
you so there's
there's a way of doing it without
telling him you're gonna break his legs
or definitely be on a recording telling
him you're gonna break his legs i just
give you a that's a 101 gangsta lesson
right there that's what you're getting
now this is 101 gangsta [ __ ] show
yeah
how to [ __ ] really hustle i don't
want to break your legs but let me steal
from you
let me take everything you got have your
wife divorce you
i mean
i'll lose my job [ __ ] i want my legs
sorry sorry
i gotta go
so that's how you started doing this
well
i was a robin and stuff of that nature
if you know what i meant by that so that
was my thing now i had a partner of mine
since dead he ran the drugs you know he
had all the drug connection and i love
people all the mob didn't do drugs they
[ __ ] were in the pizza connection and
the heroin [ __ ] in the 70s bringing
heroin from [ __ ] italy into the
pizzerias in
in new york and all it's called the
pizza connection you can look it up
online and so don't tell me that oh
we're not into drugs i love those
[ __ ] the personas
wearing out into drugs where it's a good
thing first of all
when you talk about the mob in one way
or the other
they extort it from their own people i
mean they come here from italy in the
old days and what did they do they they
started their own gangs in the streets
and they were taxing their own people at
crazy rates because they couldn't get
loans obviously and it happens with
every single ethnic group i don't care
if it's mexican i don't care if it's
irish i don't care it's italian whatever
come here have to go through those
phases until they get maybe today with
the [ __ ] technology and all this [ __ ]
is a whole crazy thing but that's so you
know it's just a way i learned how to
hustle
you know and i was the robber he was the
drugs
and then you know
i i started making so much money robbing
my own jewish source i'm bringing
envelopes back of 50 grand 40 grand hey
kid good kid
good job be careful you know
give him a diamond and give him [ __ ]
cause i was robbing diamonds
diamonds is you know people say why'd
you ride diamonds why do you rob a bank
well the money's with the diamonds
there's no money in a bank
there's no money in a bank you mean like
it's not like the movies you go in there
no no no no
no the only thing they have they have
depots i used to know cruz they used to
rob depots
depos is where they keep the money to go
to the banks
like the wells fargo depot might have 30
million 50 million
you need to track the trailer and the
guy who knows how to drive it just to
get it out i mean it's for think of that
but that's why but i can steal 130
matter of fact two years ago three years
ago i was on a show abc i think it was
what a morning show what's a george
stepanopoulos guy and they were talking
about a robbery in france they had a
robbery at a a ritz carlton in france
a guy walked in and he robbed 134
million dollars in diamonds and walked
out put two guards down put the guy down
walked out with a briefcase in his
[ __ ] hand 134 million that's one of
the big way you can look those up
so now you know what 130 take 30 percent
you get let's see you robin i gotta get
30 of those diamonds it's a [ __ ] lot
of money how are you gonna put 40
[ __ ] million dollars
in [ __ ] pallets or [ __ ] and try to
get it out and wait you know you'd need
[ __ ] trucks yeah it's not
like diamonds diamonds you could put a
hundred and [ __ ] 30 million in a
[ __ ] up your ass if you want
that's what you're into
that's how you hide them to get them to
the airport but that's something
really
go to the airport i'm already nervous at
the airport
well now you don't have to be nervous
yeah i ain't getting that
so let me stay on track here
look are you [ __ ] up yet no i'm trying
to do i got you [ __ ] up yeah i will
trying to stay on track cause there's so
much going on
so you decide
you're you say you're in your 30s now
and you're still working and doing
everything with your rob and making and
you're starting to do the jewelry stores
and buying properties i bought a vending
machine company bought bars you know you
buy things to figure out ways to wash
your money yeah you know but then you
know they you know give a [ __ ] i built
the warehouse i had a limousine i had
[ __ ] horses and boats you don't know
what to do because you're robbing so
much and generating so much you know
you're in that business it's like
they're all grow together if you want to
call it that so what are you doing with
all this money besides i mean blowing it
mostly blowing it you know gambled i i
gambled three million dollars in [ __ ]
a year to go i grabbed a quarter million
dollars in i think two weeks that the
feds [ __ ] got me what
because they they log you know when the
fbi is talking we know what you did here
here here because of taxes and
everything else
and [ __ ]
they know from casinos and i didn't
notice at the time when you put money in
a cage
in the cage and that's reported to the
irs oh yeah and when they pay you out
big money over 10 grand
report it
so you think oh let me just wash the
money i know guys who do it a little
different way now if they win 50 grand
or go cash in eight grand or leave it in
the casino if you leave it there it's
good too
and you could leave it there and go back
use it almost like or whatever and then
it's a credit if you want to consider it
a credit it's not it's your money yeah
take it any time you want but you walk
out with 50 grand today maybe 50 grand
is nothing to be honest you know the way
things are and people are and if they
see who you are if that george clooney
spent a million okay big [ __ ] deal
you know what are they gonna say but
joe schmidt
the plumber from [ __ ] the bronx just
lost 90 000.
how the [ __ ] did joe to plumber [ __ ]
you know from new york so they got 80
dollars
yeah they were smart you know they're
probably infiltrated in that [ __ ]
casino too
you know who knows exactly right i mean
you know it's so crazy because you find
out later in life that how it really is
you know who i mean i did the law for 10
years in prison and that the stuff i
read would blow you away from people not
innocent or if they're guilty they're
not guilty of the weight that they got
guilty with it's called ghost dope i did
a video on that people got to watch
that's how ghost dope increases
sentences on people
and they do that
so people can watch that on my show but
it what it is in essence is it's a it's
a dope that somebody said you did
and another person said you did and
they're all [ __ ] snitches or they
didn't do it or they did not
no they they'll have a guy in prison who
they becomes a snitch he tries to get
what they call rule 35 which gets you
out of federal prison if you snitch on
someone you're there
so they got a guy yeah larry lord yeah
he just told me about them you know they
did 20 keys here you know they didn't do
10k now that government's packing on
keys and before you know it you just
sold 500 keys instead of three keys
and all of a sudden
evidence well it's again called ghost
open then they're gonna have these
people come on stand and testify that
you [ __ ] said it or gave it to you
because they're getting a deal from the
feds yeah and all of a sudden they say
oh yeah the guy might have got
a key from you over a year
now he's going to tell the feds he got a
key every week from you
and what he did he's gonna come on
saying i got it every week from you you
know how much it was and you're saying
to your life what the [ __ ] is this guy
talking about this guy was a punk i
[ __ ] gave him a half hour a week or
whatever
so what happens is that's called ghost
dope i'm looking at dope on the wall
dope as usual i love it it's called
ghost dope though and that the federal
government does that and it's a way to
put so much weight on you now you they
don't really want you
thomas we don't want thomas but we want
rico who [ __ ] we know rico is getting
it to the next level it's a [ __ ] game
yeah
it really is a manipulation game and you
know what young people get trapped and
and i hate to see it so i try to explain
to them how the system really is first
of all the bad parts we'll get into
but like that but now look at me here i
am [ __ ] a success story and i i gotta
show you this okay yes talk let's before
we get into
a long long story
because i know this isn't going to be
that close no i'm saying because we're
going to get into the story we're going
to totally get into it please explain to
everybody what's going on cause you
explain it to me before we started okay
this is an announcement right here on
his show and it's been i've been in la
this week promoting this
we coming out we have our own cigar it's
called the crooked diamond
see the hat the crooked diamond and it's
unbelievable i'll give you some
pictures if you want to put them up or
whatever really cool stuff
and we partnered with the third largest
cigar company in the world right here
oliva and we're going to be smoking in
the you're going to smoke
i'm going to do it and everybody knows
like you're going to hit it like i will
don't inhale it i know don't i found
that out if you're puking here we got to
keep the show going right that's what
i'm here for there you go he jumps in
there
just laying down marty takes over marty
over here come on thomas move over a
little more he's puking in a bucket
so what do i do here okay
the the ends are clipped already okay
i'm gonna burn it a little bit just to
get the burn
okay
this is the world's first this and and
this is the company i am partnering with
the third largest in the
world that [ __ ] insane that's [ __ ]
awesome
okay and then start roasting it
oh [ __ ]
i feel like the sandlot i'm gonna throw
up a [ __ ]
ferris wheel
yeah nice and easy just puff
enjoy it the taste you'll feel
okay i look like two or three cigars in
my life
not this one this was at one of their
cigar year one i don't want an award and
some magazine we're going to really yeah
and uh you know i i gotta say i'm gonna
give them a lot of credit and that's
just because here
they're great guys to work with you know
i i talked to the ceo the ceo the head
of sales head of logistics and this deal
has been in the works for
more than a couple months
uh this cigar i'm having called the
crooked diamond is coming out at the end
of summer
it's right here my and i had to pick my
own blend
all of this [ __ ] and they're gonna be a
cigar that's affordable 10 cigar we have
a boxes ten dollars we have it's gonna
be amazing what we're gonna be doing
it's gonna be all over the world and and
not many people can go from being a bad
guy a gangster guy
to coming out and getting success and
now having your own cigar brand i mean
and you know what cigars the and i'm
just going to give this one to you
show me that i told you show me some
cigar guys not happy
and also it's such a relaxing way and
and you take my brand the crook could
buy more you come out
how about smoking that you had a rough
day
and just it all comes with a story of my
my life hey how about this [ __ ] guy's
day or i'm [ __ ] up
i'm smoking a cigar i know i'm doing
stupid [ __ ] i can change
i can get to be that way it's just a
motivational thing especially when
you're smoking something going yeah i
know i [ __ ] made it it's crazy yeah
it's [ __ ] crazy
this is the blend that i picked and i
had all these trays coming together and
something tangible that you could tell
story the book i'm sure you have the
same feeling with the book like i have a
[ __ ] book
becomes surreal now it's like i know but
this is like another version of that
like holy [ __ ] i have something people
are going to use and like and they'll
[ __ ] all over the
world thomas over the [ __ ] this
company their factory in belgium wow so
they're big and they're the biggest
fields in nicaragua i mean and a great
guy when we have meetings we sit in the
executive cigar lounge have some wine do
[ __ ] that's a meeting i want to go to
right who wants to go to the [ __ ]
corporate [ __ ] you know
is it good
i don't feel nasty
that's good that's got it for nothing
this is no and i'll tell you what we
could sit around with five guys i've sat
around with police chiefs politicians
gangsters so i've been over the garment
and we'll sit around smoke a cigar
and just [ __ ] like you said earlier
remember the content you could or the
people the stories that come in
conversation it's [ __ ] great and like
you and i converse you know we like that
so now you sit around with a cigar and
now it's going to be the crooked diamond
is that [ __ ] wild and they're a good
company so i got to give them a lot of
thanks but i wanted to let the audience
know because this is
really the first one this whole week
we've been talking about this is a good
podcast people are going to be hearing
about they're going to be able to go to
websites they're going to be doing
everything soon and it's going to be the
crooked diamond and they could the boxes
are off the [ __ ] chart the way the
diamond is and it's the crooked diamond
limited edition it's like your [ __ ] [ __ ]
you guys
you when you smoke with someone smoking
they go that's what larry smokes yeah
identical actually exac identical and i
picked the [ __ ] blend so see i can
see the excitement on your face yeah
[ __ ] yeah i picked the [ __ ] thing but
that that's pretty cool
were you in the cigars like
i've been in cigars my whole life oh so
this is way way cool to you then cool to
me i love to smoke good cigars dude so
that's why i wanted a good cigar i
wanted to
get a blend and everything that's a good
cigar
you know i smoke good cigars so i want
the people to know and i made him you
know we had a real long discussion
people said you could charge a lot of
money for 18 20 a cigar you'll get it
it's like a patron all this [ __ ] and all
you know people talking
and i said no
that's [ __ ] taking it away from the
people i want to enjoy the regular guy
whatever it is go home buy ten dollars
you know buy a box of cigars for
christmas or get a gift
and it's the crooked diamond the boxes
i'm telling you we're going to bring
mate that's so good and it's got a gold
band but
and then you're [ __ ] smoking at ten
dollars ago you're not [ __ ] getting
[ __ ] hammered just for the bet so i
wanted to keep it like that and well
congratulations man thank you man i
appreciate it please enjoy that's right
i brought you a box here oh this is your
box marty you better [ __ ] smell this
is your box and you can give to guests
or whoever you want it and he's a top of
the like i said this is the scottie of
in a magazine or whatever it was so
yeah come here this reminds me of arnold
schwarzenegger uh does it well this is
legendary because thomas just did the
same thing with his hhc yeah
curated everything you guys are doing
this [ __ ] off youtube bringing in these
big ass companies really you too
congratulations man thank you and and
we'll do things that's what
this is we'll partner on a lot of things
cool
it you don't see many people get their
own cigar brand it's it's because
i'm really a cigar guy it's not like
that's why i had to ask like that's
makes i know you're like when you get
that box in your hand and somebody buys
at the store you're like yo what the
[ __ ]
i used to be in trouble
and now i'm selling some cars legal [ __ ]
all over the world yeah the [ __ ] wins
that box is going out to [ __ ] germany
italy or wow they're smoking the crooked
diamond in italy
think of that i mean that blows my mind
it really does a lot of things listen i
go on a live show die i love what i do
and i love meeting a lot of you guys
because i think we're all creatives we
all enjoy what we do so much because you
can't be good at and get where you are
without enjoying it yes i don't care
what you do you have to like it at least
you have to like it at the very least
and every one of you guys i meet we all
do and we get excited and i like what i
like yes as i say but i wanted to get
back into a story too so i didn't want
to you know
everybody out there when this coming at
the end of the summer this coming end of
summer it's gonna be crooked diamond
it'll be all over the place they'll be
able to google it anything you want the
crooked diamond matter of fact we're
gonna do a show when it comes out smoke
one of mine online you know
whether you come to my you would have
coasters
listen marty get ready get ready marty
you might be jumping in a seat
[ __ ] up
oh you're [ __ ] up you know i was
hoping i had to watch you i was you know
you know you're my son's age right i was
trying you were my son's age so i kind
of look as i asked my son stop it son
don't do stupid [ __ ] like that i try to
wrap the [ __ ] puke
i'll be okay i'll be okay i did the
first time i ever smoked a cigar i was
the first time i ever drank wine i was
16 and i smoked it and inhaled like a
blunt
so i do know that i do know not to do
that
okay
let's get back to the story all right i
know there's a lot of questions and a
lot of [ __ ] people are going to want to
know well you're going to want to know
here yes and i'm going to let you take
it away because you're a [ __ ] natural
storyteller so i'm just going to
smoke a joint smoke a cigar yeah i'm
going to throw some things down but
we'll let you take it away well
you know
that does happen a lot and that's okay
that's what i want and in this this
format which i like the best
is the best because i can talk about my
brain goes everywhere like everybody
yours too you know creators have that
you you're thinking about the next thing
before you're [ __ ] done with the one
thing you got so much
and and your [ __ ] brain is [ __ ] a
nut we're nut houses we're you know we
call it rant to city over here woody
rant rant city like yo i'm [ __ ]
ranting for 30 minutes we never even
went back to that story are you kidding
me marty everybody will be for three
hours ago we never even finished the
story from the beginning
hey my guy ben's he's here so he's my
host
we do the same [ __ ] thing you know
what we had to do now we rant we have
[ __ ] things off or over but the end
of the show we're ready to upload we
don't know cut none of this [ __ ] it's
going to be uploaded oh
boom what did you talk about
we don't know
it's a blur every time
um it's [ __ ] you know what he did
last time i got to give him benz he says
i got this so he started just writing
down a little thing yeah him
he had so much on the board i said what
the [ __ ] is this we talked about all
this i really said this [ __ ] uh-huh are
you excited
i know i get i feel you like we really
talked about all that today
it's weird to see it
[ __ ] it really like being drunk
i'm telling you and then we
it's a good idea now because now on the
subject we can please put a like meth
head mike talks about [ __ ] or [ __ ]
this one you know whatever the [ __ ] like
you're gonna do like you know guess
larry law you know whatever you talked
about cigars talked about talking about
his life whatever you're going to say
you'll probably remember it may you
won't you'll probably leave and say
good guess what was his name
every time i got
because it's just when you're lost in
conversation you don't remember because
you spark like you said you go into the
next subject before you've been done
with the first
well that's just when you lost a
conversation we do that's what happens
creators and i do that and i do have my
my co-host that kind of gets me back
online a little bit like hugo mario does
that same thing uh
so that helps obviously and get online
but now we've really expanded because we
have calling
and we a yeah we figured out we have our
own discord
yes discord we have a big discord and uh
so on our show it's called anyway it's
the real deal with larry law you can
look at all major platforms and when you
look at the show
and uh
you're gonna see
how
that we date them and nate them is like
oh [ __ ] and now we're gonna see a little
more because
you know you try to get better and
better but you know what i'm never gonna
stop and i like that about youtube
this is what it is this is no cut i
don't give a [ __ ] if i [ __ ] puke or
whatever it is what the [ __ ] it is yep
and people want that of course you don't
have to share your coat anything and go
is that really what they're like off
camera like [ __ ] you forgot the
camera was there that's exactly what
he's like you know you know how he knows
he's getting better and better this
interview your eyes are getting smaller
and smaller every time and every time
and i love it
i'm sitting here and i'm gonna say
can i hang with this guy you'll be good
maybe i could i'm pretty good at hanging
yeah you don't gotta no but i'm not like
my son you know those [ __ ] guys wake
and bake and [ __ ] and they [ __ ]
they're better on it then off it
what's being said you're part of your
life i mean i smoke a lot
you smoke every day every day oh yeah
can you quit for three weeks if i want
to i don't want you you can't know oh
yeah the days i don't smoke i'm gonna
give you a little a little thing i do to
myself every year it's a little
education for the audience
every year and i party i do things or
whatever i'll say i quit for three weeks
or something i won't drink i won't do
pot whatever it is i don't go to tell my
friends oh look i'm [ __ ] quitting
i go to the bus do it out instead of i'm
a i'm a whiskey drink i'm a seven drink
i'm an old time you know seagram seven
or seven ginger right ginger
and i'll go there and i'll just order a
ginger ale that's the first thing i ever
ordered at a bar legally yeah most
people did yeah never did because you
just knew how to say it right 77 no i
got it made for me once a week i know
what that is
that's it
but but yes uh three weeks and i i quit
something for three weeks and the reason
i do that is because it takes three
weeks to make a habit i'll take you six
months to break it so if you can stop it
i tell pot smokers drug out people i
don't give a [ __ ] what it is
quit for three weeks to yourself look in
the mirror at home say [ __ ] and now when
your buddy comes marty says
[ __ ] it thomas i got this [ __ ] the best
you'll ever [ __ ] smoke in the [ __ ]
world this [ __ ] will knock your dick in
the dirt you think you smoke weed papa
and you say them hey have fun i'll see
you in a few weeks i'm just doing things
you got it lick [ __ ] but the
minute you say marty bring that [ __ ]
over
now you're not handling it because
somebody made you do something you
didn't want to do i see what you're
saying does that make sense of course of
course yeah i hate to i'm not being a
buzz kill now i'm going to party i'm not
quitting now some people need that some
people do the reset is what it is like
uh yeah the reset but for me like the
reason i always say it the reason i
smoke so much weed is i was so poor my
whole life and like yo we got some we
got five bucks all right cool one day
we're gonna be able to have a bunch of
weed and that's why i go oh yeah i'm
smoking the joint because why the [ __ ]
now i'm gonna wear their house i'm gonna
work i [ __ ] smoke a drink while i'm
out of date i don't give a [ __ ] because
it's now it's different it's like oh i'm
gonna go to work i'm gonna go to my
house
it's
do you now tell yourself i'm not gonna
smoke until the show maybe or to keep
yourself or do you just smoke any time
no i mean do you do you get up and smoke
no you don't get up waking baby i get up
and start [ __ ] knocking out my [ __ ]
and go i'll smoke a boat real quick okay
after you get yourself i used to wake up
and me i mean i usually smoke like an
hour or two a day every day and then i
started slowing down a little bit
started slowing down yeah that's more
than [ __ ] like packs of cigarettes oh
yeah that's more than cigars i'll ever
be i would smoke joints like that every
day what yeah
all right but just because i was selling
your wigs at the time
you know i had nothing to do i was just
selling weed i'm like i'll smoke more
[ __ ] it but now no i i got to be
productive i can be productive in smoke
i just rather start my [ __ ] and then
start rolling and i look at your age and
that that's really a product of your age
you know you're my son's age
you guys are at that stage now where
it's okay we're smart we partied a lot
did crazy [ __ ]
let's go get it yeah that's exactly
let's [ __ ] go get it and and i think
that's very healthy some people don't do
it that way they're smarter the younger
they don't but you got through so much
and you have so much life experience
which is more important than anything is
life experience and now you take your
passion your podcast your stuff where we
do content
and i got this now and and then you and
i we will have visions where we're going
to go how it's going to go you know
everything we're doing
and that's such a healthy thing
but it i noticed it's your age and it
doesn't matter what pot and stuff you'll
see people who can't handle it the first
time they're not doing what they're
supposed to do and they make an excuse
because they were part and they couldn't
do it good
that they got to really check themselves
oh 100
i did that to myself like four years ago
i missed a deadline for video but i was
high as hell well i'll do it tomorrow
and i saw some comments like bro you
said it was gonna be at three and it's
[ __ ] three and i'm like
i'll never do this again i always
compare it to what if it's sunday night
the simpsons didn't come on after
football you'd be pissed as a kid i'm
like i can't do that anymore that's the
last time i did that [ __ ] like no people
are waiting for this [ __ ]
to get up we're very you know we're very
productive on that too we of course you
have to take off you tell your audience
at what times you know of course all
that yeah but we post we have times you
know our we post on tuesdays and
thursdays at 4 p.m and sundays at 2 p.m
now if something don't come out people
where is he when people say is he dead
what the [ __ ] i think i took two times
off something did happen and
diary died somebody was a rumor what the
[ __ ] i didn't die [ __ ]
not yet man give me at least another for
a few years to [ __ ] smoke cigars and
smoke weed let my [ __ ] carts come out
here wait until they come out then
[ __ ] kill me
sorry uh
you got a couple fan questions here if
you want yes a fan question let's do
that before i ask my next one uh oh here
we go dope's usual podcast on instagram
we got gas faucet what was the scariest
interaction you had in prison
oh that's an easy one i i had a fight
with a guy named bonnie uh anyway he was
in india and he kept the oh the fight
was over a chair and a tv room and all
this [ __ ] now you gotta remember i'm in
maximum security prisons i'm not in no
[ __ ] prisons
and i ended up having a fight with him
in in the tv room god got pretty good
and one of the
abs touched me and where you know i'll
[ __ ] but you know i kind of stepped
back i know what was the time it was a
great guy and they protect him but the
head of the indians in the place i was
at atlanta usp atlanta worst prison in
the country at the time
was a big day home chief and a
[ __ ] was like six six [ __ ]
whatever
and
after i [ __ ] beat this guy have a
latin king crazy [ __ ] multiple
life sentence comes up to my cell and
goes
now i'm i'm due to leave this prison
because my security level's going down
so i'm getting to go to a [ __ ] to me
it's a great prisoner obviously other
people didn't want you still at a
[ __ ] high level but i but it was like
crazy and he comes into my cell he comes
in
when the chief comes we got to kill him
we got my [ __ ] i'm like what the [ __ ]
has happened i'm still hyped up from the
fight and all this [ __ ] seconds later
yeah after the fight and the ab stopped
it and everything it was all right and
the guy was never right this is nobody
ever ratted it wasn't like that
and i'm [ __ ] he's again when he comes
i'll kill him we get him when he comes
in the door and i'm like my whole
[ __ ] life
flashed in front of my eyes
and i'm like what the [ __ ] i said no no
read away and reno just crazy because i
helped this kid reno be a bookie in
prison and he was a killer i remember he
was going to kill the guy he said today
i said leno i had to call him off with
this other group larry you know him well
you're talking i said [ __ ] pay him
you own 40 he's gonna kill you
they end up doing all that [ __ ] but
comes up to me says
rita goes oh that [ __ ] crazy story
but so he wants to kill him and then i'm
[ __ ] just you know relax
[ __ ] relaxed [ __ ] i'm hype
up i'm in my and i got shanks i'm ready
to go you know that's how that goes
and the movement every every uh in
prison that you don't just run around
when you want they have moves like the
six o'clock move the seven o'clock and
the eight o'clock moves the last move of
the night then you have to be locked in
so i knew the chief was coming back at
the eight o'clock move and one and word
already went out you know to the to the
different [ __ ]
and all of a sudden i'm up in my cell
and in comes walking i see a [ __ ]
shadow now in prison
you don't enter a door it's open you
knock on that [ __ ] frame of that door
you i'm in maximum square they'll kill
you for that if i was just walking in
yeah who do you think you're walking
it's my house you know this i live here
[ __ ] this is my house
and i did crazy [ __ ] to people because
it was my house they didn't shave crate
i told stories but
this incident i [ __ ] the chief come
up to the door
knocked and i'm in there ready you know
like just he knows i'm [ __ ] i'm swam
you know i'm hyped up
he goes we're good larry
we're good
and i'm like all right you know like
what am i gonna say no we're not i'm
like [ __ ] want to kill him now no the
other guy was whatever he's the boss
apparently the ahead of the abs of the
place and powerful guy talked to him
and they you know like hey listen larry
wasn't in a wrong on this one you know
it happened what it is i stopped at a
point and larry wasn't wrong because
i'm like thinking
holy [ __ ] but to be honest for the next
10 days i was in there i used to put we
had folding chairs i had to put a
folding chair even though the place was
locked folding chair i had my shank here
another shank ready to go because i
don't know if they're going to come in
at one of these times rush me and
[ __ ] you know oh it wasn't really
good or the guy and the guy was an
indian and he wore a headdress so his
eyes you couldn't see the swelling in
the eyes you know the structure you know
he had he needed stitches you know but
he had he had the big lips so it didn't
matter you know what i'm saying he was
well hidden and never added good dude
man you know i get a lot of props just
think words got twisted the wrong way
and that [ __ ] can kill somebody in
prison you know so the scariest thing
was like i'm gonna be here for [ __ ]
ever
no no no no no you know when i got up
when i was facing life no i meant
because you're like we have to kill him
i'm going to oh
that's exactly what i'm thinking i had a
date see they call it you know when you
have a date see people in federal prison
when they have
a life in prison they don't they call
them letters
you got letters you're never getting out
there's no
parole 25 or this [ __ ] you get life you
got letters on your jacket and you don't
leave that prison until they say dead
you know or whatever the system
now i didn't have that
i mean the person that had a 2 000
inmates 880 at life that crazy [ __ ]
place
crazy place but
forget that those prisoners you can look
actually it's funny because in atlanta
if you look up the usp atlanta
penitentiary i'm one of their notable
inmates
yeah why oh i don't know some [ __ ]
fan [ __ ] said you know you're on the
notable side of the united states
penitentiary atlanta i mean i was there
and all that and it tells what i did and
all that [ __ ] and what i do and stuff
but the al capone is there [ __ ] the
guy from i said i'm in good company
if i'm going to be on a list at least
it's that funny yeah that would be a
shitty one
good question what did you say faucet
gas faucet i recognize the name that's
why i picked that good question i just
saw it
that was a good question okay so
my question leading into this you said
you're about 15 18 million dollars deep
stealing all these diamonds and jewels
on your run and how long of a span did
it take to steal that oh sure uh my run
was from 1989 to 1996. i had a seven
year old years yeah two years
you know who wanted me
the people who hated me the most now you
gotta remember this uh uh thomas i
didn't [ __ ]
uh hurt people i wasn't beating people
we were pistol whipping them no they
were getting wrong robbery it was it was
rough i'm not trying to justify anything
i did i realize i'm not
uh but
the people
every store i rob
let's just say they made money
they put an insurance claim in one time
the fbi comes to me goes larry you got
1.2 million out of that store
i said you know what i got about 800.
he laughs you know because he knows that
the owner just sold the [ __ ] store
and made more money listen you get
robbed you own a store out here and you
get wiped out everything in that store
you just sold an insurance company yeah
i guess so right yeah so you know who
hated me the [ __ ] insurance companies
they hated me the fbi when i got caught
a guy's name was matt mullen he was a
nice guy too
he was looking for you i i i was looking
for you for five or six years because he
they had my mo but they didn't know who
i was
and i didn't know that they [ __ ]
flood the areas with fbi agents i'm
after by the big boys i ain't if listen
state police
much respect
they suck
so i mean they don't have the resources
they don't have the money to follow
people to do it listen the fbi wants you
they'll send the [ __ ] f-16 the
[ __ ] miami and bring a witness here
in [ __ ] two hours you know what i'm
getting at him yes
all out all the money in the world so
you're robbing these places by yourself
no i have a crew oh okay how many people
up three
maybe four okay in my crew even five out
of six
let me think who else is not in jail no
[ __ ]
they're all not everything's done
this i ended up getting arrested in 96.
so seven years yes from 89 and this guy
is going who is this man for five years
and he tells you you have to look for
you for five [ __ ] years oh yeah
he said he was going to retire
swear to my children he said that i'm
the retired
he goes i got your ass i'm gonna and he
was nice of an irish guy and he was at a
philly office too the major case squad
when they did they put you on something
and it's like they they're [ __ ]
rabbids you know [ __ ] they're gonna
get you so never [ __ ] with you i love
people oh the [ __ ] fbi
[ __ ] you they're good yes they got all
the money in the world all the time and
when that agent retires or dies there's
another [ __ ] sitting in his exact
position exact case ain't [ __ ] go to
a local police department they lose a
budget the guy [ __ ] retires this guy
didn't [ __ ] do the game
where's it going yeah you know but don't
[ __ ] tell me the fbi
that is the u.s of [ __ ] a oh my god
okay so seven years they're looking for
you
you you guys are robbing these places
walking out selling i'm assuming selling
this getting your money you don't know
well i had you know it's not you don't
just sell it that's how people get
caught you have fences
you go to your fence he takes the
[ __ ] you bring a fence a million
dollars in diamonds and i negotiate
after going through the whole thing i
walk away with 350.
35 depending you know that's the 30
percent i you could just give a rough
estimate
but and sometimes watches are certain
things are high end and he'll want it or
diamond is so perfect you literally got
the [ __ ] on a table and
now at the end
more i got so close with him and i just
drop it off
i knew about what it was he'd say come
on get your money and i'd meet him down
in little italy new york and i'd always
go to [ __ ] positanos or ilka teals
see i never forget i got a bracelet too
at a restaurant yeah i can brace it for
you it says larry lauren i'll never
forget i got it for all you guys i love
this you like the [ __ ] memories
[ __ ] this this will do me good doesn't
bring back all the crazy [ __ ] no only
kid the uh
but
uh ilcoteels or positanos we used to go
and i would have a bag of cash
[ __ ] i'm eating my vodka rigatoni oh
i love vodka rigatoni and the pasta and
and i'm a big guy and i was big i mean i
got to my my heaviest was 300
you know now i'm a svelte 240.
you you couldn't hold back could you
when i said that i heard it from marty
yeah the [ __ ] skinny guy
the [ __ ] skinny guy's always got to
laugh at us fat guys come on a spell
no listen i'm wildly out of shape right
now
so you're walking in you're getting so
comfortable go ahead just i trust you
give me my money and yeah i mean i got
to know him back very well so
in movies when the diamond people steal
everything they go to a warehouse that
has one big light and they split
everything yeah yeah
yeah such [ __ ] you know i did a
video you got to watch it it's on vanity
fair it's got about 11 million views
and i uh
i uh review movies
that's how i got into youtube they
[ __ ] me and i got into youtube
real they were reviewing vanity fair
hired me
to do a video not hired me they paid my
expenses from florida new york this is
vanity fair you know big time [ __ ] yes
and they wanted to do this video with me
and and when we discussed in a contract
they ended up doing two videos actually
but
we're in there and we do this video on
robbery they produce it now let me tell
you people don't notice the 24th floor
no freedom towers all studios
owned by connect travel studios around
the whole [ __ ] 24th florida world new
freedom tower
so i go up there i go meet friends
before we gotta get [ __ ] up
drink it we have a 491 lick of that
liquor belt and we get [ __ ] up my
brother was there and then we i go to
the shoot the next day and i'm a
professional what time i was there you
know call boom boom we do this video
now the contract the thing they wrote me
was hey if you get 150 000 views to 180
you know that's good and all this
within the three week p you know how
youtube works he says we're going to
discuss a contract with judy you fly to
new york do videos all week like we'll
make a good contract
so
this is a great story because
i [ __ ] do this show
necessarily two two years of sick water
not even six or two years and three
months or whatever ago
and i [ __ ]
uh i'm waiting and now this video is
[ __ ] getting views i'm calling a
buddy of mine in new york billy he says
billy maybe he goes they're gonna call
you that [ __ ] they got the golden
[ __ ] goose they get a [ __ ] coin my
brother who says coming in every day he
goes how many more and every day [ __ ]
subscribers i have no youtube i start a
[ __ ] youtube because they they don't
call me
vanity fair doesn't call me never even a
thank you [ __ ] never even a
bottle of scotch said man this this
video to this day there's 11 million
[ __ ] views on there so he says
so i don't hear from
and that people contact me i don't got
any of this [ __ ] i opened a [ __ ]
youtube bam bam bam bam bam meet a kid
it was edited good
everything we do so we're growing and
this thing's just blasting off
i get an email from [ __ ] vanity fair
and the email is
can you please sign the release for the
second video
mind you these [ __ ] never even
said
great video budgets change weekend is
about you know thank you never paid my
491 liquor bill
pissed me off now you're [ __ ] my 491
dollars a liquor
so
we go and uh
he sends me this email and that it now
they can't release the next video in the
account without my signature
i'm a [ __ ] thing i'm a crazy
[ __ ] i go on linkedin
i [ __ ] pay for the service and i find
out who the ceo of [ __ ] contest
travel the [ __ ] parent company the
ceo the cm i'm getting all their emails
from linkedin and business deals
put it in the thing i write back
not only do you not have permission
to uh use any of my content what was in
that contract i'm very disappointed you
said this you didn't do this you didn't
even pay my 491 dollar bill like i
didn't say lick on it in the email
and [ __ ] i hear back from
one of the big big wigs there
and
said first of all three days later i'm
in the office teresa's in the office she
goes i just got a check for 491 dollars
i still [ __ ] i i didn't know it
didn't click yet i ended up [ __ ] like
she said okay i said that's the liquor
bill for that one for the accountant
[ __ ]
anyway
[ __ ]
i get an email saying mr law we're
really a pilot now i'm blowing up i'm in
the hundreds of thousands already of
[ __ ] subscribers a million yet i mean
listen i i hit million faster than
anyone almost like one year a week over
year we hit a million subscribers [ __ ]
right i'm on one year yeah and what i'm
that i'm at a million four i think it is
but we're growing we're doing crazy [ __ ]
so listen to this you're gonna love this
and that's in a year and a half this is
two years i'm only in this thing two
years yeah
all because
a [ __ ] vanity fair but the ceo said
people's heads rolled they dropped the
ball we apologized we hoped we could do
business in the future and that was it
didn't tell me even sent the 490 but i
can guarantee someone said send that
[ __ ] money and we gotta
somebody better email them and try to
because they you know they're big
corporate people and i think they run
you over like oh who gives a [ __ ] it's
like oh he's pissed
oh he's not going to sign this [ __ ] and
they're like oh we need him now he would
be nice to the guy [ __ ] right [ __ ]
dicks and you know that's corporate and
you don't get that with little guys i'm
starting to deal with us guys you know
we we to make a deal we can [ __ ] make
a deal and handshake in
and and i love that i love that yeah we
we've uh dealt with some
with some corporate people when we first
started we didn't realize
that they don't give a [ __ ] about you
bottom line
i thought you were a nice dude
[ __ ] you man next thing is tom thomas
who's on the phone i don't know who the
[ __ ] thomas is will you how much yeah
oh i don't know where that's at well
it's coming soon
it's another division let me patch you
through mm-hmm hey right am i marty
i get so [ __ ] mad i want to get in
the car and go down there and bust
somebody's [ __ ] head over yeah
that's what we said like yo
i know where you live
but that's a different story we're nice
people
that's exactly what we said like we know
where this man lives right
i'm just going to get my money from him
or take something from him this is how
bad
this is going
fast in the show
well i bet we're going fast what what's
that 112. oh
no i'm here i said but it's fun because
you know there's so much my life is
crazy you know i mean when i say crazy
i've been shot i've been stabbed twice i
stabbed two people
had 11 hour back surgeries other
surgeries been [ __ ] rolled in a
tundra street times never dropped my
cigar
the whole time no [ __ ] whole time
that's what you only happened a year and
a half ago or something like that never
dropped my cigarette i swear i'm driving
45 a [ __ ] lincoln hits me broadside
goes straight to everything lights
stop sign in the rural area where i live
just hits me at the right otherwise they
said another foot you were dead
but anyway hits me it rolls a tundra
brand new [ __ ] six week old tundra
it's rolling me down i got a cigar i'm
going to a poker game
i didn't drop that [ __ ] cigar the
whole [ __ ] way i'm on my [ __ ]
there's someone here knows the story he
was there and and i was [ __ ] having
such a blast
not like i'm hurting i had a concussion
i'm [ __ ] bleeding a little i'm doing
all this [ __ ]
and i'm [ __ ] i got my cigar in my
hand i was calm i make a phone call and
you know like you'll never find a guy
smoking a cigar that's not having fun is
that how you got your door
there's my new tagline you can roll
three times in a tundra not drop your
cigar and you know you're having a good
day i made a call
yeah oh [ __ ] right
minus concussion but with seven already
what the [ __ ] i got eight of them now so
what's eight you know what the [ __ ] it's
only right you got a deal it's like some
pro right it's only right you got the
deal
um
any questions
we go off on rants here yeah it's okay
yeah yeah i got a question for you uh
that was the one
well i remember another one
you don't even know yet you already
forgot what we talked about earlier no i
already know what we're talking about
talking about chief and all that was the
first one no that was that story but
before that what are we talking about
yeah
and wait which part
that was a lot there's a lot
are you do you ever play gta online
heist missions matter of fact one of my
big videos six
six million views
is me reviewing
a gta game
of a heist and i have gone on there i've
played i do videos a friend of mine is a
guy with 5.6 million subscribers expert
thief
he's a good friend of mine he considers
me almost like his mentor dad mentor you
know with life
great kid too really a good kid expert
thief but uh so i do go on gta i occasio
i have not gone on
i'm not a fan of gaming per se i like
gaming or whatever but i'd rather have
like a seven-year-old kid running the
controls let me watch some crazy yeah
that's because that kid is good it's
like a movie you're not a [ __ ] yeah
and i do the same thing my cousin plays
wait kill all these fools real quick
yeah and you just watch it smoke a joint
look at this [ __ ] because they're
like movies right now oh
cut scenes or movie scenes yeah you know
we do have a pretty good gaming audience
too uh that want me to do more and more
but you know you know as well as i do
man
this is work this isn't like i'm doing
it now let's go
you know what i mean i'm 100
and people don't get that and now gaming
hours out of out of life like yo i got
businesses
this has to be a business or i can't sit
here and play games
it has to exactly 100 and that's where i
look at it now
and but that's your answer for gta
matter of fact there was a whole push
online to get a character of me in gta
oh dude i'm like easy envisioning how
easily that could be we're easy we're
getting pretty deep in that world on
this show we've had some
big gamers on yeah i've had franklin the
guy who played uh i've had lamar nice
you know i've had you know oh yeah
franklin no what's the head guide of the
the leicester
oh
you know for a long time on gta i was
reviewing games and i used to call him a
punk i said that [ __ ] ain't no
leader if that [ __ ] was the leading
[ __ ] i'd let that guy talk to me like
that i'd [ __ ] kill him lester's a
punk like lester could never [ __ ] run
my crew
people were going out and putting hits
on leicester and games
i swear to god it's [ __ ] nuts and i'm
[ __ ] like and
the gang goes like everyone let's take
over lester it's on reddit and survey
all this [ __ ]
and it's kind of funny like that my son
was just talking to me about uh gaming
and gta and my editor
actually told me hey bring the bring the
whatever thing is what's the box
or the xbox
bring the [ __ ] xbox
like when the [ __ ] do i got time to
[ __ ] sit and play [ __ ]
we played it three times see i got it
you get it we're trying to build a
business around it yeah if i can build a
bit and
do that
because the fans want it
it's fun video games are fun what they
want exactly the same thing hit that
that'll do good oh yeah the hash browser
yeah george too
tropical melon
bomb
good [ __ ] and this is the cigar dab the
right thing
like that's the next business we're
getting in no pot business nice
well well you know we want to think
about we were thinking let me just put
it even putting up a podcast that's one
of the things we're thinking we're also
thinking of maybe having our own strain
uh you know a pot that's really good and
whatever that's given
yeah and again i see you guys doing that
yeah well you know it's part of our
demographics like yours
believe me on our demographics are yours
we are 18 to 44 83 male we're like
ninety percent male 1
we're 92 overall but i'm talking about
in that demographic what i just said for
advertising but for the oh overall we're
92 or 94 percent male yeah yeah we're
saying yeah that's what i'm saying we
had that's why this is i said that's why
people would i've had people say when
are you going on this show when you're
going on your show oh dude it's nonstop
people ask all the [ __ ] time and it's
funny because i always saw the name go i
don't know what that is man and i'm
scrolling that like i said i was on the
one night
get this [ __ ] guy who is this guy we
need him on the show and that's when i'm
like oh that's the person they keep
[ __ ] asking for i'm thinking even
coming out to l.a more like once a month
renting the house and doing [ __ ] so you
know out here it'll be worth it for you
yeah i mean the people and all we can
all do you know all of us get together
and and one thing i matter of fact uh
one of my guys was saying is true
youtubers tend to help each other you
don't see them being [ __ ]
i haven't really been anything i haven't
really and and you'll see others all you
get the [ __ ] world is you know how
big [ __ ] youtube is
taking it away from me yeah you're
[ __ ] there billions of people
watching it you know
you know what i mean little hierarchies
like in like stand-up comedy and like
different things there's like a little
there's the cool kids and all that [ __ ]
that's not really like that yeah right
no it isn't it really isn't i've noticed
that you watch everybody and you do and
you just you like the person for
whatever you like them but then and then
like we meet and then now you said then
you get hooked i remember i should ask
liara on my show when i have you on the
show it's gonna be the same [ __ ] we
should ask you should i ask that [ __ ]
but we do that every time of course why
not oh [ __ ] because of my notes i didn't
even
i got one right now so what what advice
do you give to just andy dufresne just
your regular guy you're a regular prison
guy going in for the first doesn't
belong there like terrified
right okay yeah i mean that that's just
the question depending on what they did
and where they're going
you know if you go to a camp you're a
doctor and you [ __ ] [ __ ] off on 15
grand or whatever the [ __ ] you know some
[ __ ] and you're doing three months
in prison that's the [ __ ] camp that
let's face it that's a vacation for you
and me right now we go to wait for three
three three months ago you know what i
needed that you know but get the [ __ ]
away from everything
you know not a phone [ __ ] just [ __ ]
it you know
get in shape but that's a whole
different animal than
going to
even a low but a medium or high that's
tough and if it's a high
that's a tough and it depends on what
the crime was it a sexual aid it was a
we call you know
drug crime robbery crime that kind of
you rob an old raping old lady and the
people you know they remember they got a
mom they got a dad you know
kind of a honor code as stupid as it
sounds but it is one
so that you know that's a that loaded
question yeah
yeah i can imagine yeah that'd be that'd
be [ __ ] horrifying just like is there
is there a path of not being gang
related if you're just
yeah and it depends on the prison and
can get rough and summon it depends on
your age and how you handle yourself you
know a lot of people said larry man you
made prison but you're a big guy you
know which i am a pretty good fighter
big guy
but it was never that that survived me
president it was the brain
knowing [ __ ] before come knowing who to
talk to knowing who to be around
that's the kind of things i think you
look for in people period yes you know
because listen i don't care how tough
you're there's someone tougher always
you know i don't care everything and no
matter what
thing we're going to talk about that
that's just a given you know so then you
have to use your brain
and most of guys like us or whatever
it depends you know sometimes they're
not they're a [ __ ] corporate geek
that doesn't gonna be [ __ ] up but then
there's a street kid you know and
understands where they're gone it's a
nerve-wracking thing but
okay you know i know how to talk to
people i don't want to shut my [ __ ]
mouth i don't want to say something i
don't want to piss someone over i kind
of look around what's going on you know
the feet the pressure you can feel
tension in prison that's the one thing i
tell people oh you could feel i would
imagine it never stops like i would
imagine you'd never you know there's
times when no we we'd [ __ ] get high
and do [ __ ] and do all that crazy [ __ ]
and you've got to be comfortable around
certain people even though it's so crazy
i always say that you know my seller he
killed a guy with an axe handle but he
was really a good guy uh-huh and it
sounds so [ __ ] up now when you think
about it i knew another guy [ __ ]
killed a guy and cut his head off with a
shank
but you know he was nice to us
so he was you know
how does that sound when you think about
it i think about people you know he just
said he was a good guy and he killed
[ __ ] two people in a [ __ ] with an
axe handle
you know that is yeah your baseline for
judging people has to be different like
you have to you have to take it
with the situation like yeah he murdered
four people but
he likes me
he's nice yeah he's a good guy were your
ties on the streets did it make your
life easier in there oh yeah mine for
sure because of the mobsters but
in even other people if they knew one
guy guy can voucher him room from the
neighborhood i don't know how good that
is when your neighborhood's all going to
jail you know true
so this is going to lead into that exact
thing
you
you said uh the guy catches you says i'm
retiring
what happens the day the guy you get in
trouble when you finally get caught for
seven years 96.
i got you because i want to lead into
what he's asking about jail yeah he
catches you what do you do that day you
wake up the day you get in trouble
what is the day
what is that that's the helicopter over
the house [ __ ] movie [ __ ] that's what
i'm wondering the
my i said i had a a town house with a
[ __ ] nine foot bar at this time it's
96 computers were nothing i oh buy now
i'm bookmaking i'm the biggest bookie
from south florida [ __ ] central
florida
and
i had a computer and i remember i had
like a six-time modem and whatever
[ __ ] car i don't know what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] was all i know is three
years later my son's [ __ ] nine i tell
him i got him a computer he says that
thing's a piece of [ __ ]
so that's three [ __ ] years and he's
[ __ ] nine years old he don't want my
[ __ ]
so anyway uh
so that day
you know i there was a guy we used to
have steaks and [ __ ]
it was like a party house you know
obviously
and my wife i have a 15 month old
daughter at time you know during the day
she thought she says oh you know i think
someone was following me now i think
over that's true he said that she
thought said that like i'm thinking
but i think
mobsters know how much you're making
this and you know trust you know you're
in a world of
not the [ __ ] most you know honorable
people so you're wondering who's foul is
it the cops is it this
now a month before this we had a getaway
of a [ __ ] crazy robbery in [ __ ]
fairless hills pennsylvania
you know the shootout and all that kind
of [ __ ] not shoot out because i didn't
shoot back
but anyway
we go uh
at that day and [ __ ] she goes she has
my daughter on her arm she goes out to
get the mail at the end of the
cul-de-sac
i hear her scream
they're coming
i jump out of my [ __ ] chair
the door flies open it's the ninja
[ __ ] i turn around and go out
the back patty with the jacuzzi there's
[ __ ] coming in with the [ __ ] masks
and this [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
helicopter high up above
this is at five o'clock on a monday
some neighbors no they don't know i'm a
gangster but some think i'm this nice
good this good guy and boy they [ __ ]
weren't for a shot that day because they
closed off the whole [ __ ] cult this
like at five o'clock a night i mean it's
totally done then the guy again the fbi
puts me down i got three grand in my
pocket
uh three grand in my pocket [ __ ] you
know rolex [ __ ] nice sneakers and i
know jail what the [ __ ] i says
he says
you know i say listen can i give my wife
the money and the stuff in the ring and
all the shoes yeah they didn't even care
hot watch not jewelry money cat sneakers
change them they weren't [ __ ] you
know what i mean they did their job they
weren't trying to do more than they had
to do they they were cops that had a job
to do they caught me mine was to always
evade them
it is what it is you know what i mean so
i'm okay with that
i'm okay today i tell young people even
ratting i said what is rat and all this
i tell them this
you and me doing a crime and you getting
off time because you could tell on me
that's right
you get your mom getting robbed in her
neighborhood her calling the police is
not ratting
[ __ ] got robbed she's a civilian
she's supposed to do and catch you if
you're stupid enough to [ __ ] get
caught you're a [ __ ] jerk off and you
shouldn't have been robbing the old lady
anyway
if if am i making sense 100 percent it's
as clear as you could have put him in
okay if you don't get that what the [ __ ]
are you doing like there's more stone
than we are
a hundred percent they are i hope i hope
everybody at home is just ripping bongs
right now you can't really smoke bombs
on youtube because youtube would get
pissed at that so we keep it to the
joints oh is that what it is they don't
mind the joints yeah we kind of we try
to like just tiptoe on this tip toe yeah
he's got a full wheel have you been shut
down you haven't been demonetizing my my
regular channel
my big one has been deleted before but i
got it back
so i do all my weed [ __ ] on there it's
just and you gotta back you you you made
the argument yeah marty got it back for
you good for you yeah made the argument
that it's entertainment it's whatever
yeah i did all that
a little different you know how that
works right there you know guys
what the [ __ ] did we do today i i feel
you but um
so sorry i got off track a little bit
he he's
they're coming you said the ninja's in
basically they put you down they let you
change your [ __ ]
well no not just give those items give
it away and then i'm cuffed there and
they had a warrant for the house but all
they had was for me
and any excess of cash
and any jewelry equipment or [ __ ] like
that
and they did miss cash because i had a
safe in my bedroom under the rug and
they didn't say yeah it was 50k in there
so they missed that
and they but they weren't again they
really wanted me they got me i'm sitting
on the curb and then they take me in the
car and they go to at this time in 96 it
was one of the new facilities
that they had the fingerprint machines
you know where you put your thing on
each prong then you know remember the
old way [ __ ] yeah yeah
this is the real you know
so they processed me to do didn't even
ask me questions [ __ ] didn't do a
[ __ ] thing i didn't ask them they
didn't ask me we both knew what the [ __ ]
we're here for you knew what it was for
what the [ __ ] yes the fbi ain't coming
down your door because you're [ __ ]
like mother teresa or rob the [ __ ]
beer at the corner drug store so
how if they if they've been looking for
you for so long how did they finally
realize that it's you yeah great story
you know the last robbery i was telling
you about
a lady where they were shooting yeah but
that was
that's robbery of the store before the
store we were casing other stores
and i went into a store
and i looked at a ring but i did not
invest didn't rob that store but the
lady took my plate number down because
she wanted to sell me a ring she wanted
to get you know come back because i was
looking at nice expensive rings that's
how your case stores
so she's really so she just happens to
have my plate number
i don't know this of course at the time
look at your face that's what he's
saying oh and i'm sure the same way yeah
let me tell you so
what happens is
she [ __ ] the lady has this one i
don't know this of course the fbi when i
when a robbery happened of my my modus
operandum the way it's done
the fbi flooded the area they [ __ ]
checked every jewelry store in the area
and went in it was anybody trying to ask
these questions before the case in it
they went in they they confiscated every
camera in wawa stores and [ __ ]
7-elevens and they actually got me that
in one of my convictions i am seen in a
a wawa store next to the jewelry store
the day of or the day before
in savannah georgia
it was savannah georgia robbery one of
that robberies so they know you're there
i might marietta i don't know which one
it was in georgia for sure
because of the states i don't know but
that's how they [ __ ] got then
i'm not even on the car because it's a
rent-a-car
i'm not on the car
fat tommy who works for me is tommy's
350 pounds
i'm not 350 i'm a big guy but nothing
like that didn't look like him or
anything
but i was the co-driver like you know an
add-on because you had to have in case
you had a legitimate accident
and once they ran my name
the [ __ ] flags went up the [ __ ]
thing organized crime busted for drugs
six months before or whatever you know
[ __ ] all the crazy [ __ ] and then they
got me and then
they ended up convicting me on four
stores
and i don't know how many millions but
they closed 21 22 cases
and
i was opposite of 18 million
all from just that
[ __ ] that's how you get taken down
because the ladies don't really wants to
do her job well
exactly oh
[ __ ] i had to know but you know what
this is a true story or true feeling i'm
glad it happened
because it didn't happen at a time where
it got crazy someone to get killed i had
planned a robbery before that that's in
my book about kidnapping the owner and
[ __ ] getting 12 million out of a
fountain blue hotel an eight stern
jeweler
and
we had dynamite ready to put on the wing
i take the family hostage and make him
go in the morning and get the diamonds
with me and i'll have dynamite on him
and if i tell him i got this thing if
you pull over this cops you hit someone
i'ma step out of here and i'm gonna hit
this button you're gonna blow up and
your family's gonna die if they don't
ever hear from me every you know hour or
whatever it is because we got a guy back
at the family
never happened obviously because if it
is that's no statue of limitation so
even if that robbery happened i wouldn't
be here yeah you get what i'm saying
guys so it's a different charge it's a
big big time federal you know it's
kidnapping and it's the whole works
so
why you know being caught if you want to
call it probably saved my life
you know in a lot of ways get out of my
business get more power i was getting
jewelry you know and then you know you
get become bigger your limo you get into
this before you i mean you're big in
this system but it's gonna crash like a
[ __ ] elephant on a [ __ ]
mouse and it does some at most 99
i got busted probably luckily
because we didn't plan that next crazy
ice or whatever because if i didn't
and i did one more and it was the wrong
one because the fbi asked me to go
you're so good you had so much money you
did all this [ __ ] why are you [ __ ]
doing this
you could retire and you know what it
was
we like pot or whatever you like acid
i'm an ass and nutty
[ __ ] there's better high there than
i've ever had in my life
really
yeah yeah you know it was a high that
you can't explain
and i've done every drug so it's not
about drugs it's just knowing that it's
an adrenaline it's an adrenaline thing
that you beat the system you beat these
people you want to be a fly on the wall
and that [ __ ] thing it's just crazy
you know yeah and when you think about
that you say that's the ultimate high
everyone chases everywhere you chase the
best high that's why people do different
drugs they talk a little more you're
chasing that perfect high you had one
time or where or you want to get to that
perfect high same with with this that
adrenaline i mean there's nothing i can
do to get to that high
maybe it is maybe i can [ __ ] make a
conglomerate and [ __ ] save [ __ ]
half the world i don't you know what i'm
getting at the [ __ ] knows but it's just
that high and a lot of people don't get
that but did your mind stay change about
like what path you wanted for life
during your time in prison or was it
through like the vanity fair thing and
now no no no no no no i was doing good i
developed the number one program in the
country to help people
you know i'm the only ex-con in the
united states who's an honors honorary
cop
what look i i get that you can look it
up online
listen i developed a program it's called
the reality check program this is true
it's the number one program that helps
young people stay out of trouble
and it's even used by court systems and
police agencies and everything oh wow so
police agency calls me
and
you know how i am because i haven't
changed even [ __ ] before youtube or
anything
they [ __ ] come to me they said listen
you know we
we use your program we love your program
we'd like to you know fly in and vet
your program and come on anytime you
want police chief was a sweeter to this
day he's not a great friend and
everything
so he comes back and then he goes back
home and they talk about my program and
this they want to make me an honorary
police officer now i've been offered
that and i look at the police department
if their jerk officer said go [ __ ]
yourself you know but this police
department
they don't give out [ __ ] tickets for
[ __ ] they don't give out awards in the
police department for the most arrests
or most of you you know he gives out
awards for the cops that help the person
on the street with a flat tire
he gives out an award for the guy who
speaks at a church or whatever it is so
he's not he's rewarding him for doing
[ __ ] that's for us you know for the
people and i love that and he's true to
it true to it is a [ __ ] day is long
and then i said okay so
there's a big ceremony around this whole
country abc sync you google it
everywhere every major network had it on
i was on every tv station in the country
being sworn in as the only ex-con to
this day it was honorary police officers
that's insane what a feeling no i hate
no no i'm saying that
i don't like the way some cops are i
support good cops big time if they're a
good cop they're doing the right thing i
often tell people oh the cops suck [ __ ]
the cop
your mother's getting robbed do you want
to call on nine one one or four one one
hundred percent i say it all the time
define the police so when you're getting
robbed who are you gonna call right
right what are you gonna do so i want my
mom to get the good cops but you also
have to have cops that are into the
cities he'll into the helping of people
so when they catch a kid smoking weed
bull in the [ __ ] or whatever the
[ __ ] he's doing they don't ruin their
life
that's why you need more i've
encountered one in my whole life isn't
that sad
is it cause you're brown maybe is it
cause i don't know you don't know
i don't know but we're all drinking i
was all right guys all right guys come
on support mal clean it up and leave and
i'm like yo thank you because i have to
graduate this week i would have been
[ __ ] it was the last week of school
i'm like that's the first cop i ever met
that was nice to me
good [ __ ] but i see what you're saying
so i don't say [ __ ] the cosgo [ __ ] that
cop right oh i do that all the time if
the cops i look at him like what a
stupid jerk i watched a piece on 2020
about this quinn family and [ __ ]
things she gets kidnapped these cops
[ __ ] it up so bad i go what the [ __ ]
are these morons doing you know what i
mean it's terrible
but you know but again i support good
cops and these people they they actually
gave me the badge
here's another one that'll [ __ ] you up
i'm the only ex-con in the united states
to be recognized on the floor of the
united states congress
i am in the congressional [ __ ]
records
how can i join with you
[Laughter]
so what i mean what a feeling i'm saying
when you're in jail going this sucks
to one day i'm going to be getting
recognized on the floor of congress
how [ __ ] up is that i mean that's
that's the path you're supposed to be on
but isn't it because when we do
accomplish crazy [ __ ] like how the [ __ ]
is i was just selling packs and merced
and then now i'm thinking i can't
believe this is real so there is that
moment where you think holy [ __ ] it's a
powerful mind just depending on what
it's being applied to yes basically yeah
it is and it's amazing when you say that
because it's you know you look at it and
say okay you did that
it's great
you did this but you still strive for
more you strive for that you know as a
disabled vet i can actually physically
retire
pensions all this kind of crazy [ __ ]
but i love what i do so much
you know and i want to see the young
people around me and people all grow and
make this [ __ ] thing so big again the
cigar brand
that's [ __ ] huge because it's all
over the [ __ ] world you smoke a
crooked [ __ ] diamond that it's like
best
i'm a cigar smoker a legal thing that
i'm going to do that i actually like
that's why i had to ask if you're scar
smart because that's even
it's even
like stronger for you you know what i
mean this is something you are
passionate about people are hearing this
for the really first time this is the
longest time we sit explain what we're
doing with this thing and everything i'm
[ __ ] glad this is great i can see it
on your face you're excited that's
that's what we're here for man this is
awesome [ __ ] yeah accomplishments
oh yeah sick all right now one more time
something
when i got out of prison 2007
i ended up getting out and a friend's
cousin larry i need a favor
i said what the [ __ ] do you want me to
break somebody's legs they just get out
of prison leave me the [ __ ] alone
he goes no i caught my now this is night
2007. he goes uh end of 2007 he goes
because i got out august 24th he says
i caught my 16 year old smoking weed and
he told me [ __ ] you dad where where you
ever been
he's a successful guy he's a golfer
gopro
and i says he said i said your dad told
your son told you that 16 year old kid
i'll speak to your son
i [ __ ] go in i happen to have
pictures of kids who are dead kids that
are you know things murdered and ass has
got a lot of bad [ __ ]
so i said the kid now he's a big kid but
i'm a big guy too you know so i sit down
i says
you uh two curse words too i said you
told your son where the [ __ ] he's been
you've the way he's been i'mma show you
where the [ __ ] i just come from
boom
look at him start showing him pictures
telling about time losing my kids
everything that goes on what we're
talking about
the guy [ __ ] two hours later [ __ ]
i come out and the kid's like you could
see him change you know you could see
the [ __ ] kid change
i said to the dad i said see what
happened he gives me a hundred bucks now
i got money
100 bucks he goes larry thanks again man
can i give your name to some people or
sure so now people are calling me for to
talk to their kid 100 bucks and say wow
but i develop a program
now called the reality check program
that is used in court systems by police
agents it's a four part program of this
what i used to talk about it's an hour
video i'll send it to you holy [ __ ] and
i'll send you a link so you can check it
out it's pretty good you know the video
was built in 2010 and that video to this
day is so relevant and people say don't
ever change it it's so raw you know
you'll see rawness especially in the
business we're in and you'll go wow but
it's going to catch you to [ __ ] say
you know and that's why they don't want
to change that but i developed that i
still have that so
and so that's the part of me like i love
what we're doing i you don't know this
is great but i know you got a heart and
you like to help people you don't want
to see people [ __ ] get [ __ ] up on
[ __ ] addiction or robberies or this or a
bad life and you don't want that
you know that's not your heart yeah you
know we're hard we can be hard i can
tell you go [ __ ] yourself i'm sleeping
the street [ __ ] but you get what
i mean it's hard
to be good for everyone until they [ __ ]
with you right that's really 100 yeah
so my next question since i know we're
getting parker
so we we asked about it you get caught
and you said it's probably for the
better because it saved my life
essentially from what the perspective
you're thinking about it
so
you go in day one you say you're in
atlanta oh in prison itself
yeah when was the first you well no you
go i went down to a florida uh detention
center ftc miami it takes like months
for you oh yeah well you go there and
then you gotta go for your trial you go
you whatever you know i ended up i beat
a life sentence otherwise i wouldn't be
here
so i mean however your case goes it
takes it takes a year that's i was
almost a yield to the day actually
and i went to uh atlanta then
the zoo starts i mean you know you're
talking about one of the worst prisoners
in the country at the time and they sent
you there because of how much well yeah
well i was violent technically violent
crime
also i wouldn't [ __ ] roll they
i'm the only one who went away on my
case
what do you mean nobody went away
hey like that kid oh all that manpower
all those resources and money behind
trying to track down and
oh
wait a minute eventually my brother gets
caught you know how
his [ __ ] ex-wife told the [ __ ]
police
eight days before the statue of
limitations oh
[ __ ] [ __ ]
eight days
i don't know who's listening to that one
but they're a [ __ ] huh
sorry ladies and i don't mean that about
you out there i mean my girlfriend use
that word when when someone's being
[ __ ] so no okay okay
i get it but i don't want people that
they gave me yeah but if it was it like
deliberate like oh yeah [ __ ]
deliberate they got the [ __ ] phone
messages got the phone calls everything
that happened oh i feel sick for him
yeah now my brother and i are very very
close and he he lives right near me and
we were very close and uh he did he
ended up having to do nine and a half
years just about 10.
oh
god damn look
okay so so
you're the only one that goes they're so
[ __ ] mad at you that you won't say
who else is with you well no i cost them
in 2002
i get another conviction for filing a
false statement to the fbi
why because i lied they said who's my
partner i said john rodriguez
where's john rodriguez miami
did you know the federal government
spent over a million dollars
investigating every john rodriguez in
miami that's reckons it's on the record
you read the whole case why would they
believe you like you're gonna listen i
added more time
i ended up getting 12 more months but
they ran it concurrent oh okay cool and
i didn't give a [ __ ] at this time i got
[ __ ] six convictions in the feds i
don't give a [ __ ] right give me more you
want you want to take yours so you don't
have one what do i give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
pablo escobar is my [ __ ] partner go
find him yeah and find him right
well almost but and they researched and
[ __ ] you should have seen their trial
they wanted me to take the plea and i
wouldn't
because if i did it my brother couldn't
win the appeal which we didn't win an
appeal from but that's a whole nother
show
so
it's [ __ ] like
they [ __ ] were trying to make me go
so bad because i'm costing the
government mega resources
we had freeway rick ross on here same
[ __ ] judge judges hate on the jury
it's like [ __ ] po they'd rather so
they ended up the prosecutor says to me
goes
all right we'll give you 12 months and
run a concur we'll recommend 12 months
because with a federal judge they could
tell you go [ __ ] yourself
so he they said we're going to recommend
the 12 months run concurrent night okay
then if you agree to a bench trial me
i could because there's still a trial
they can't use this for my brother i
said okay let's do the bench trial
so we get in there
we [ __ ] present our case he prevents
is he wins it's a [ __ ] easy case you
know but when he comes and presents the
case he brings in this [ __ ] hand
truck
full of [ __ ] files and paperwork and
all that [ __ ]
he's telling the judge how they went and
cost the government over a million
dollars we investigated we even
investigated a john rodriguez in a house
and he was in jail and then we
investigated that family i'm hearing all
this [ __ ]
and i go oh [ __ ] and was really no
[ __ ] you know excuse here i mean it's
already proven that i lied in my
brother's trial
so
we're [ __ ] sitting there and i go i'm
dead man this [ __ ] judge is
gonna slam me so the judge
if you've ever been in a federal court
they don't [ __ ] around they lit it's a
big high [ __ ] feds don't [ __ ] around
it's an intimidating place
so
i'm in it i don't give a [ __ ] really i'm
already in prison six years i'm in the
worst i wasn't the worst of the worst
ah [ __ ] you give me another three i
thought i was gonna get three more years
at first because that's the most they
could have gave me i think it was and i
said i'm gonna get another three tacked
on and they're gonna run it consecutive
this then this whole happens so the
judge gets up
says okay i find mr lawton guilty you
know we say okay we like to
wave pre-sentence investigates psi's
because already in prison nothing's
changing
they agree they agree
all right recommendations so my guy gets
up
oh you know mr lord has been in jail you
know they should forget about the you
know we recommend nothing because we you
know this does not hurt anybody it was
he was trying to protect his brother and
all the [ __ ]
prosecutor gets up and says all this
[ __ ] you know how i'm the devil and i
[ __ ] trust them a million dollars
so the judge is like this and judge is
sitting back and i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
you know he's gonna give me these
[ __ ] years the [ __ ]
he says
uh prosecutor goes what do you recommend
this so the prosecutor says
12 months just to run concurrent with
his sentence which is nothing really
the judge leans back in his chair
he tells he goes stand up to the
prosecutor i go i'm really [ __ ] he's
gonna he can slam me this judge i mean
this is a federal grudge they don't have
to [ __ ] listen to you in it they are
god man it's not like states
so [ __ ] the judge [ __ ] goes
you just told me this man
cost you a million dollars he lifts up
this paper boom
and now your recommended time what am i
missing here what the hell is going on
how do you do this and put me through
this is the judge like oh [ __ ]
and then the judge tells the guy sit
down he's pissed this [ __ ] at this like
in other words why did you bring this in
front of me this [ __ ] never been in
front of me get the [ __ ] away wasted my
time and i and i and the you know
defense stands you know i stands he goes
looks back he takes his gal he goes
who am i a federal judge time wrong
concurrent
i lean back and holy
i mean
i just [ __ ]
just made three years more of my life
you know i mean that's what the judge
could have slammed me i mean they can do
anything they want they're fed so it's
crazy
story that's my last conviction
so
and since then i've been clean
except for this murder i was involved
with these three guys in uh uh melbourne
florida now i'm only [ __ ] around the
[ __ ] out
[Laughter]
okay so so my question is
they got so upset at you that you
wouldn't say anything that they put you
in one of the worst prisons in america
well yeah my original prison i went
that sounds right
i'm in prison and uh i'm in louisburg
pennsylvania
so
we're processing and they're sending me
to the [ __ ] you know i get
transferred i asked the guard the guard
says to me goes
[ __ ] lot and you're going atlanta who
did you piss off
this is a [ __ ] garden another
penitentiary goes oh that place is a zoo
and sure enough when i went up there
uh
there was a murder a month for a year a
murder a month not counting overdoses
not counting suicides not counting
guards killing people i'm talking a
murderer month there was a zoo people
were getting stabbed all the time it it
when they brought in this crazy warden
named uh willie scott
he cleaned the voice up you know
so i mean and he got i mean he's a
[ __ ] jerk off [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] warden
just to let you know how i feel
so you so you get there and you realize
it's a [ __ ] zoo like you said
what's day one like
in prison no for that prison oh the real
prison i was in the hole for a while
they leave they leave you in the hole
until make sure you don't have any what
they call separatists is this anybody on
the yard or this [ __ ] i have none of
that nobody's in prison i'm well liked i
happen to be lucky because i brought in
a
a
kite with me
and it was for a boss a mob boss named
vic arena
vic arena was in the colombo wars in the
90s where they had killings [ __ ] and
like 12 deaths in brooklyn you know
marble
and this guy was one of the guys the
bosses and whatever shot and all that
[ __ ] well he got where i had a message
for him through people
and then they looked you up and now
you're with them he act he actually gave
me a big bag of commissary and all that
[ __ ] the first day i was on the [ __ ]
yard i asked where's vic
saw him at lunch he told me meet me at
six kid i know he went in he did all his
due diligence he made his phone call
whatever or somebody in the street they
go yeah he's he's a good guy
and then once he hears that more you
know we need more good guys you know and
if you're in that
in the east coast they don't call it the
car like that'll do on the west coast
you're with those guys you know and when
you're with you get your protection you
met the mob guys and
they had too much politics too but it's
just typical of any [ __ ] group gang
or any of the [ __ ] things you deal
with and i dealt with all the m.a i
dealt with no tenuous
aztecas latin kings g27 yet there's you
know
aryan brother harry circa every nation
dirty white boy i read i dealt with all
these [ __ ] gangs you know max and
sarinos
especially you know they were i used to
like the
border brothers from back texas they
were i knew a couple of those guys real
guy i knew a couple of sun angels real
good
so so you're in atlanta and you're
telling me there's
sorry i don't think of mexicans in
atlanta
you know you know cubans actually had
the biggest riot in america the cubans
took over atlanta in 1987.
they took the whole [ __ ] prison
hostages and everything cubans from
[ __ ] maralitos
the ones i brought here
oh [ __ ]
the ones i legally for the government
full circle full [ __ ] circle you
remember now huh see i got you i'm gonna
catch you oh no i don't know we'll be
[ __ ] up see we can handle it here
we're good we're good
okay so you're day one and the the story
i watched
uh that that got me like oh okay we need
to bring him in and this is where
full circle we're right back to where i
was gonna start in my head
so it was like a fight story or
something like that
where you
you had to crack somebody with a tray
no with the mop handle mop head
yeah that was in the land it was in
atlanta there's two bathrooms in the
back
now once you everything that's handled
with everybody
you can do what you're going to do you
got to do what you got to do they tell
you
so me i have a [ __ ] mop you know
there's my bringer down the gym this is
down at the gym area in atlanta it's the
same prison that we're talking about the
zoo one yeah zoo one i mean there's so
many dark spots we call where there's no
cameras and [ __ ] like that well anyway
in the in the gym when you come out of
the bathroom there was a mop closet and
i knew how to get into the mop closet
but [ __ ] then you go down and i took
a mop handle a [ __ ] metal mop for you
this guy's a big guy but you know you
got to do what you [ __ ] got to do so
the he he went to the bathroom after the
recall that 3 30 recall recall recall
everybody go back to their cells
so we do that
he comes around i see his shadow like
but you could feel shadow darkness from
the light
i will the [ __ ] mop ringer and
[ __ ] crushed his [ __ ] face
he goes down i'd [ __ ] drop the mop
ring i [ __ ] go back to my [ __ ]
cell
boom he's [ __ ]
sure enough
three four o'clock count this is prison
man every day four o'clock is count time
four o'clock count they usually let us
out by 4 20. you know they start
unlocking doors they clear count
they ain't clearing count
ain't clearing count
here it is 4 30. quarter to five usually
[ __ ] chow was running already man this
is gonna [ __ ] up the whole yard
six o'clock
no [ __ ]
they found the guy of course and [ __ ]
christ you had to go to medical you know
all the [ __ ] that goes along with
getting your face crushed
and [ __ ] they kept us locked out
until they found out after them they let
us out and then they found out it wasn't
a uh
the only reason they locked prisons down
is when they have
like
i kill you and now they think the
mexicans are gonna start a war
got you you know what i mean i don't
even know if you can cities of
mexican-americans kill you get what i
meant yeah yeah and and then once they
find out it's some personal beef
yeah you didn't pay me for a [ __ ] in the
card game or whatever the book crazy
nuts we are
then they say okay open up the art they
want to make sure that there's not
there's not a riot
oh [ __ ] okay so
yeah and i survived that prison system
uh you know in a way
with more like i said my brains than
braun i mean you had a fight when you
had a fight of course and i party there
were good times bad times pressure times
and all the prisons and i fought the
prison system so they [ __ ] transfer
me and they can't you know i've been on
con air 16 times that's the [ __ ] air
that's a real thing i watched con air
three [ __ ] days ago that's a [ __ ]
real thing but they don't have the
things on the feet you know what it did
on the [ __ ] plane but yeah i reviewed
that movie and i talked about the
[ __ ] part of it and [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah conair
i was on i played 16 [ __ ] times
getting transferred yeah i was over that
i had frequent flyer miles for conair
why are you getting transferred so much
huh why are you getting transferred
because i was [ __ ] with the prison i
mean i wrote letters to the media i had
congress [ __ ] evolve that's what
helped me because i i exposed deaths
going on in prison
the prison was killing people through
medical what do you mean
letting people die literally a guy
friend of mine walked out of the medical
department
comes into the unit is his boss already
all week tom go to our doctor you know i
guess he
had pains and all this [ __ ]
they gave him may locks and connie walks
in their [ __ ] door and he walks and
he says to me and another guy named
jimmy brown he says
i'm dying
we put him in a chair
he literally keels over and [ __ ] dies
yeah if you've ever never seen a man die
when they die they defecate themselves
they you know that's what happens you
open up whatever's in there and it was
actually the spot and wetness on the
ground after we knew he was dead
because we start trying to give him cpr
and the guards are screaming locked down
locked down you know they call medical
all that [ __ ] but
i was in a cell looking at the whole
incident
and those [ __ ]
were laughing when they had them on the
stretcher and poking and taking the golf
cart from the front of the unit up to
the [ __ ] mountain they were laughing
they didn't give a flying [ __ ]
and he was [ __ ] dead and they weren't
[ __ ] pumping his chest they weren't
doing anything like that
and he died he died of a heart attack
obviously a massive heart attack that
they that's just one of them there were
two others so i wrote lettuce to [ __ ]
congress i [ __ ] did i wrote media
articles i did all this [ __ ] and it got
it got attention and they hated me and
they put me in the hole and they beat me
for 11 straight months i was strapped
down naked beaten and tortured and
pissed on by guards what the first three
pages of my book damn read the first
three pages in my book three pages
you got a book if not like did i send
you yeah we both got okay
so
and you know and then you i survived it
by being a fighter by never quitting you
know having that and seeing you know i
don't want to see kids
you know part of when i was in prison
and the older you get my reputation was
real good around the whole system
stand-up guy he's got to fight his
assistant don't give a [ __ ]
i saw too many young people come to
prison
you know they think they're badasses on
the street they hit that [ __ ]
places where i was at
it ain't no joke you know
you know it's [ __ ] real deal there's
murderers there's [ __ ] hitmen there's
mob bosses there's drug kingpins there's
guys like me armed robbers you know i
didn't give a [ __ ] you know you know
come from the streets
that's smart officer you know we're
talking penitentiaries now i'm not
talking like uh
you know uh little county jails or
anything and [ __ ] yes so it's the real
deal and i saw too many people come to
prison young people
and man you see them change so quick
from thinking they're bad they'd realize
right away man
and uh i saw too many coming and then
before you know i seem hooked in the
gang or even if they weren't and
running with the bad crowd doing this
and [ __ ] and not going to change their
lives you know he's they might have a
lot of time but you know kid having 20
years is you know at that age you're out
in the 30s you know it's not even like
oh you know you look i i went away at 34
years old and i got out at 46 so i lost
the best years of your life
you know the and the best years
you know like meet those 34 to 46 is
your best earning years best [ __ ]
years i don't give a [ __ ] what it is
it's the best believe me
you know and good to know it's good
yeah you get you'll get there
he's getting there
almost i know
that and that's what i uh didn't want to
do that's another reason i do what i do
with the kids and the help you know and
been in schools and speak all over the
place on them you know
and obviously
the entertainment part of it came from
being on tv
being a casey anthony expert being on
jon stewart [ __ ] funniest great type
you know uh the comedy central yeah for
sure [ __ ] great [ __ ] show oh he
was [ __ ] great man
and a nice guy and a nice guy
and then being on all the abc news shows
and from fox to cnn to msnbc i'd be
their go-to expert for a crime and
that's for for you from you writing all
this got that attention
writing all these letters to congress
well no no that's that saved my life in
prison i'm talking when i got out oh no
i'm saying when you got out you were
just kept speaking and that's what got
you all this yeah well i helped that kid
and then i got in the court system then
i kept speaking that's what it meant
that's what yeah earlier i told you
about the kid that i helped his dad told
him [ __ ] you that kid
since that time and i developed the
program after that
that's when we did what we did that's
why there's so much media attention but
you're saying while you're in there it
saved your life in writing all this oh
yeah because they would have killed me
if i didn't have support coming back
into prison when you write a letter out
of a prison
in a prison they they write it back in
it's all signed for and [ __ ] it's no
joke they can't oh i didn't get that
person's letter and if a congressman or
senator write a letter to that prison
and they ask about they have 30 days to
answer that congressman
now you as a citizen never give a [ __ ]
you know i think i'm going to give a
flying [ __ ] but if a congressman writes
them and says i'd like to inquire about
what's going on with mr lawton's
situation him being in a hole for x
amount of time already
they have to write back well he's been a
bad inmate whatever the [ __ ] they say
the [ __ ] they all come up is pretty
almost stocked answers but now they know
they're on the watch from a congressman
so they're not going to kill you because
they'll kill you don't think they won't
the guards will kill you and that prison
was notorious you know and
i was just a fighter i was in edgefield
and i just
i'm a fighter and then i got like
instead of going crazy what do you do
don't
think you don't
i got that that energy back to fight and
fight and i'd write letters and [ __ ]
pencil and [ __ ] you know doing all
the crazy [ __ ] together there's almost
stories but it's it's crazy my book you
read that part of the book it's just how
i added being in a hole there
and that long and how you survived three
years out of 11 and a hole
by yourself you're [ __ ] sometimes you
got a selly but you're just so [ __ ]
sometimes trying to kill each other you
know i mean it's not like oh i can do
what i want but most of the times with
me i was a violent inmate so they that
was alone
my brother was in the hole he said he
was talking to ants and [ __ ] he started
going crazy
there's no question sad as it is people
look great they've done many many
studies
on the uh effects of isolation on a
human being and it's not good i mean
we're social animals we talked about
that earlier
and then you try to you know [ __ ] with
that's why rehabilitation and i talk
about it in a different sense everybody
wants to think give a car give him a
high you know transportation job he's
great no
it's the psychological people don't get
that is the hardest part of
reintegration into society
and it's not [ __ ] the uh get him this
get him the guy's [ __ ] wired
when i went to prison when i i when i
got out of prison i was making a hundred
choices a day
today you and i marty everybody here
gonna make a thousand choices uh not a
thousand you make oh yeah you make a
hundred in as a thing and you're gonna
make 1500 choices as an adult when
you're gonna get up we're gonna smoke
what time we're gonna start we're like
we're
i want two cups of coffee africa
whatever the [ __ ] everything that you
make choices of you don't realize yeah
you take a poor inmate don't know
clothes don't care everything's the same
times this you get programmed that's
called institution and i was totally
institutionalized and i was an
intelligent guy got a degree you know
read the paper did all the things you
think is good well i need a joint or
something no more
did you know you were going just a
little more
like did you know you were getting out
at what point did you realize that you
weren't like gonna get the life sentence
oh i knew that before i got in i beat
the life set it's pre-trial gotcha okay
so that's that that makes sense and what
was life like how were they gonna do
live you're just robbing people because
they the law states if you get convicted
with a firearm
you get five years for the first robbery
20 years for every robbery after that
running consecutive not concurrent can't
run
so
just the just the [ __ ]
three four robberies is 85 years before
they give you the sentence for the
crimes or another 10 or whatever the
[ __ ] doesn't matter it's 100 years in
prison that's life yeah yeah at least at
least i don't know anybody who's lived
to 160. well i'm thinking at that time
i'm 34.
[ __ ]
god damn okay so
you're telling me that
you're writing all these letters like
you said you're writing letters and
that's saving your life but isn't the
attention is why are your life's
endangered well it it it was like a uh
a dual thing
totally
if i stop then they then they
might kill you anyway if you keep going
digging hate everywhere you go
how's it going
but a good
got me my eyes are closing like yours
the uh
what happened was is
uh where were we at
you say the attention writing the
letters is what's getting the attention
of the guards without that you say it
saved your life because they have to be
on point oh yeah you know at the end you
know i i stuck to my guns they ended up
respecting me man i was on the yard i
get out of the hole and you're you're
white you think i'm white i look like
[ __ ] snow [ __ ] white you know
anybody comes out of the hole get no
skunk if you're if you're a brown i
guarantee you will be look coming out of
there looking white oh for sure i mean
in the hole there's zero suddenly you
know you're [ __ ]
anyway i'm walking the yard i was
smoking a cigar the nah blaze cigar
that's the best they had in there
because
i guess i smoke good cigars
so anyway
we go and uh the warden associate warden
comes up to me goes lawton
i walk over i don't give a [ __ ] about
him now i mean literally i'm
if he wants to throw me in a hole throw
me in the [ __ ] hole i know he can
obvious and all that [ __ ] but i didn't
give a [ __ ] he said yeah i come up he
goes
you need to stop writing senators i said
listen to me he goes no he goes wait
we'll give you a get out of jail free
card now in prison that means if i get
caught drinking hooch i tell a god to go
[ __ ] yourself i [ __ ] get caught with
gambling
they're gonna give me a pass you don't
have to go to jail jail is the hole in
prison
he goes and i'm we're going to give you
your own cell
single cell in prison that's like
[ __ ]
the hyatt [ __ ] you know regency
because you don't get them you know now
you got your own [ __ ] cell huh
look at that
better than the condom i'm looking at
just to stop writing the letters yeah
that's what they're trying to prove yeah
that's right they're trying to bribe me
and i said to them
he go i go why don't you just not do
what you did to that black guy in the
hole
and he [ __ ] stopped short because i
didn't give a [ __ ] you know i
what they did was there was a veteran
who had no legs he was in the hole i
wrote an article about it it's on it's
own song you can read it i'll send it to
you and the [ __ ] andy and the i said
the [ __ ] you guys are torturing it
that the guy they let they didn't give
him they let him defecate on himself he
couldn't do something with the water i
don't couldn't move i don't know the
place smelled i had a lieutenant
and it's in this article come up to my
cell with a camera that like bigger
camera they're going to lose you know
it backs up to myself knowing i'm a [ __ ]
i'm writing senators all the time i'm
[ __ ] a fighter you know he literally
said to me he's filming the cell when
they're cleaning it and they got the
guys in the suits and all the [ __ ] and
he says to me he goes if anybody saw
this video somebody in here would be in
jail
meaning that he's taking this footage
you know
i [ __ ] write a letter i i quote him
his whose name was lieutenant infinity
and i [ __ ] the little he was
lieutenant i said i never forget
i am
the elephant
and he [ __ ] uh
sure enough
what we're talking about
i never forget i remember
i'm the cameraman you quoted the camera
i ended up getting transferred again
again i ended up going farther away from
florida
i ended up in forest city arkansas yeah
yeah what the [ __ ] is so funny she
pushed him to the middle yeah just get
him the [ __ ] out of here
so
there
they did they help this man with no legs
essentially what you're saying yeah
they were abusing everybody man
i mean literally you know they don't
give a [ __ ] they these these places are
[ __ ] animal they they don't look at
human life like you and i i understand
that they really don't man it's [ __ ]
sad i don't know how somebody can go
home treat somebody like that and they
go home and oh honey i had a great day
at work
you're a psychopath [ __ ] psycho
you have to be to turn it off go i'm
going to start there's something [ __ ]
wrong you just torture someone piss on
his face
and
uh what the [ __ ] hi hun i had a great
day you want to pee on me now
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so that that's what one
thing i was gonna get into yeah my
stepdad told me a lot about all of the
whole process and
he tells me like you know how many
people die that you don't see in the
newspaper he's all guards kill more
people than anybody
but what i don't understand is how does
a guard walk in as a government worker
or state
getting paid
and how does that person not get killed
also
because you know you're they they have
the authority there the police
essentially
but they're also in a room full of
people that well they they they have
assaults on them they have certain
things and there'll be certain places
they'll be with other people they might
be in a tower at this time because they
[ __ ] limit her in the truck or
whatever or they might be in a position
it's not as easy just to hit a guard but
oh i've seen it many times they in
atlanta they tried they stabbed a
district prison official on a [ __ ]
inspection round right in the middle of
it for a ten thousand dollar hit i think
you could look it up somewhere
somebody paid ten thousand dollars to do
it to get this [ __ ] prison director i
said it was on a [ __ ] inspection he
[ __ ] did it
[ __ ] went up and stabbed him on a
[ __ ] prison yard
jeez he's just with the clipboard i mean
well he you know they were with an
entourage of people i don't know how it
happened and all this [ __ ] and it was i
mean i heard about the first time i got
there
jesus christ
all i can envision is shawshank as he's
saying
is a good movie and it's got a good
basis i like it but
obviously it was an older prison that
but i was in an older person just like
that i was in atlanta it was built in
1903. damn
[ __ ] dungeons in there 40 foot walls
20 feet underground three feet thick
try to get out of that [ __ ]
and people have
so
you're in prison you say you're six
years they try to convict you again he
says concurrent get the [ __ ] out of here
why is he here
so you're doing another six right well i
still yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
so i'm halfway through my time let's go
so hitting [ __ ] with my panels
is this having you have to do this all
the time not all the time obviously but
you have to
you know you have to either protect your
honor your word or obviously
if someone tries you because you know
you can you can [ __ ] be the [ __ ] and
it can go to a bad way quick
you know i don't care how you fight you
gotta fight yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're good or
not does not matter
you know what i mean uh and that's the
truth
so i think that's that's what people
don't know and and then it's how you
handle it i mean prison things happen
you know you know i i was involved in a
lot because i
i'm an action guy you know you got to do
so whether it's book making whether it's
uh something on the yard you know
betting and gambling you know having a
football ticket you know what i mean and
now you [ __ ] got a store man that you
supply him and he makes money for you
you know it's kind of like you know you
get into action when you get attacked
you got to do things to people so they
know you you're for real you know
i'm not into action to give it to you
when you [ __ ] come hard on me you
know you're going to get stabbed
[ __ ] oh
i just picked up my friend from jail
just got his ass out last week took
[ __ ] forever for guys to get out i
think they would be on time with the
release dates
come on man i'm out you're waiting and
[ __ ] they don't give up give up
i don't care i'm getting paid
two hours let your mom sit outside [ __ ]
you it's cr anyway i just picked he was
telling me about some things and he was
telling me about something i don't know
if you've ever heard of this you
probably have he told me like yeah this
[ __ ] one has a no hands policy i go
what though oh
does that mean
no he's like in he's like in our block
there's a no hands policy and go what
does that mean he goes you can't fight
you can stab each other only
is that what the [ __ ] i've never heard
of that before if it's not important
enough to get stabbed over then let it
[ __ ] go
i'm like is that a real thing i've never
heard of that anywhere yeah that is that
is [ __ ] crazy but i've seen some
crazy [ __ ]
i mean i've seen you know i've seen so
many [ __ ] shanks and [ __ ] that
kind of [ __ ] i see [ __ ] that look like a
[ __ ] sword and i said this guy's
gonna go fight that through someone well
there's different places you know in
atlanta it was an old old prison so we
had [ __ ] we even had the [ __ ]
plaster walls that we made a hole in and
you could hide a key or something down
there on a piece of rope and then you
take wet toilet paper
and you make it like that and then you
paint it over
we had the color paint and it looks like
it was like you know
you know looks it was you know like
plaster
perfect
but in fact
our [ __ ] key is taping up against the
wall so we can go get it and that key
can open something
you know really you have nothing but
time in there [ __ ] planning
how we did that were you were you
tripping balls in prison you said you
were doing acid and [ __ ] oh man that's
my favorite in prison you gotta ask oh
thank you for that question i took four
hits that [ __ ] aston once i left
atlanta i swear to god i floated out of
prison i've been looking for that
[ __ ] high for the rest of my life
remember i was telling you we're all
looking for that was a i mean it i was
hovering over the prison i did it in
prison i was
hovering over the [ __ ] prison
oh that's the easiest [ __ ] in the world
to get into prison essen's like yeah
it's got to be the easiest it's like you
put in a book or something a card a
letter a [ __ ] you can make the whole
card a piece of acid take a hundred hell
of it and a little thing get a
corrugated card soak it all up that's a
hundred hits of [ __ ] assets damn how
much does one head has to go for in jail
25
it's not that bad oh no no we still know
we used to get it in so we used to sell
half and [ __ ] take cash oh my god
i'd be tripping the whole thing
i'm not kidding you some people like you
know i've seen guy have a bad trip and
jump off a tear
but but i most of us just want to get
the [ __ ] away so we put our headphones
you better get a battery pack because
you're going to be up all [ __ ] night
i couldn't imagine psychedelics in
prison oh my god
was that the most common what was the
most common drug oh heroin
heroin by far why it's because you could
just sleep they think they were on a
[ __ ] nod and be out of it and that's
why you get a lot of overdoses are the
guards really looking like are you on
drugs [ __ ] no no they don't give
a flying [ __ ] as long as you're not
causing trouble
because if you're causing trouble then
then you're in trouble
oh so oh yeah back to my question
how are these
how are these guards doing what they're
doing
and it's not an everyday looking over
your shoulder
sorry this is a this is strong
that's good
yeah yeah my son is laughing at that
he's a big big smoker you know
well i have a
bong just about as tall as you in the
back
um
so yeah that was the question i always
thought of when i see
when i see documentaries i'm like how do
you
i mean because
you can make a phone call i know
[ __ ] if you can make a phone
call and get [ __ ] shot
right now
what is the same thing for a guard you
know you they literally
you see some of that but there's there's
so many way they monitor every phone
call we have that you know they've
they've stopped many stuff that has you
know have and stuff has happened it is
more common in the state because the
state know each other like you know you
know you're a prison guard you might
have been in high school with this dude
that dude you know it's it's very common
and the feds
you know there's so many and they're so
[ __ ] massive over the [ __ ] world
you know they send me the ark who the
[ __ ] i know in arkansas that's it you
know
i'm gonna do that on purpose and then
it'll be hard to get the you know stuff
but there has been i used to always say
to myself
and you know i was with some big big
[ __ ] people i used to say man why
don't i [ __ ] you know he i would have
a helicopter go through the wires try
this get you know i always just said you
know that's that's what i always try to
figure how i would escape you know for
sure and [ __ ] i'm wondering why they
wouldn't do it or try because i know i
talked to my brother [ __ ] like
he's stealing a helicopter
you say the big people that are in there
like how are you not escaped yeah
and they go oh that i was with nikki
scarfo
you know vicarina patti amato these are
mob bosses man and drives with willy
falcone
why the [ __ ] don't you [ __ ]
helicopter this [ __ ] that
helicopter wire
they call it but you could still drop a
head i'd try some [ __ ] man i don't know
oh for sure that'd be my routine all
right this month
i'm tunneling it out next month i'm
swimming at it like
whatever it takes just to get [ __ ]
keep trying rub your head against the
wall
did you ever really consider that or
just because uh no no i really didn't
because i had a date but i used to say
how i would do it all the time but i
wouldn't consider it because i had a
date yeah you know i would somebody if i
had no date there's no question
what do you think how would you have
done it do you think
you know there was blind spots and it
depends on the prison you're at and how
you think you know sometimes you could
do smart ways they do have groups come
in if you can really
mimic somebody and get them to get you
out you know maybe your crew
you know something of that nature again
helicopter is probably would be the best
but they have towers or something but in
some they don't
now they just have the roving trucks
now they now the penitentiaries all have
the [ __ ] towers and they're gonna
shoot but you know what's the odds of
hitting you [ __ ] with a [ __ ]
rifle from [ __ ] whatever
take a shot and they and are they really
gonna shoot do they know that's not a
hostage situation you know follow the
thing but you get right to a drop car
drop away [ __ ] stone leave the
chopper boom jump into a car go another
[ __ ] two miles drop a car now now
you're gone yeah now you're [ __ ]
blended in mm-hmm and you know they they
don't know what they're looking for you
could duck and that's it
yep
all day if i was sitting there that'd be
all i'm thinking about like how many
cars is it going to take for me to
switch to get the [ __ ] out of here get
down to that zero
oh you're getting down to it you smoking
all the way down oh yeah baby oh man he
loves this [ __ ]
so
you had 12 years real quick you had 12
years and you're doing all these things
you had my panel this this that i'm sure
other things happened you never got in
trouble enough to where they had to add
time on i i lost game time so that's
like adding time every time you go to
prison if you go to the hole and they
give you a uh
sentence of 28 days that's game time
all your sentence no that like you get
every federal prison has to do 85 of
their time
well
that's calculating how many days you
would get off every month and it's
whatever it is
so when you go to the hole you lose 28
days let's say or 14 days it's like so
in a way they're sentencing a matter of
fact there's been a lot of law trying to
test that if that's a new conviction
because uh you know it's really it's
it's totally not arbitrary you know it's
a dho discipline hearing company officer
you know you you get in a fraction for
whatever
and they never ever ever side with the
[ __ ] inmate you know what i mean it's
it's [ __ ] it's
it's both you know
[ __ ]
so your story is not like many all right
many people that get out
and be successful i mean
yeah i did i'm an actor i'm [ __ ]
making music or doing this and this is a
whole different route right you're
talking about the things you've
experienced in your life
you have a never-ending job because
you're you
i mean you never of course you can run
out of stories eventually in 30 years
but it's not like you can't just keep
going and keep talking to a new person
now this is a new route and now you're
having this and now you can talk about
the
yeah this is a whole different
did you ever see yourself
at all telling about your life
and actually making a career of it no
not even
not even think i never thought about it
you know there was a lot of things i
know my story is interesting i always
knew that i know a good story teller and
all that
but i don't know if you know
the way it you know look for you look
for a tv show in this and i get off of
this [ __ ] and that [ __ ] you know
i was doing certain tv and then i
learned how much the industry's all
[ __ ] i mean you know the tv i mean
it's here now obviously it's youtube
spotify where are we at you know it's
more now internet based and all that
so and then i fell into this through
that that i told you about the vanity
fair thing so i fell into it and then it
now
i you know you think wow like you said
wait yeah holy [ __ ] you [ __ ] bobble
your head
and now i look to make it bigger with
the cigar brand and and other things and
so many partnerships i say there's
there's so many with our industry you
know we do a break you know i mean
there's so many freaking things you can
do yeah when you have a platform to do
it with and you do good with while
you're doing it so
and always the number one thing here
from all three people right now with the
microphone just be yourself absolutely
man i don't give a [ __ ]
when that is that is the biggest
statement and i'm and i don't give a
[ __ ] some people you're crazy
listen if if life was
to be [ __ ] bottled up
who [ __ ] wants to live it man
live your life be who you are have fun
respect others
you know
respect others like you want to be
respected
and and it's a great [ __ ] world to
live in
[ __ ] you know come up with [ __ ] you
know you do your thing you know like
it's just amazing what you can do like
he said sitting around smoking a joint
having a cigar
and it's wow
all this [ __ ] content gets created
ideas are going and that's what it is
yeah and the number one thing that we
just said it's just
we started off when you're just when you
be yourself you don't have to remember
things you just talk i i i already
forgot whatever we talked about but it's
in my memory it's like when i watch you
oh yeah that's right that's right i
remember i mean it's not even just that
i mean i say you know the story i i
probably told you know whatever times
it's just cause that they are what they
are you can't it is what it is there's
no
oh no no you shot no what are you
talking about exactly look back
20 years or now i'm out since i'm out 15
years now wow
congratulations yeah it's a whole nother
life
that's a whole nother lifetime of time
too yeah and now it's just starting so
awesome let's go what a story
uh what time are we at right now
2 25. oh she's looking good looking good
looking good before we get out of here
can you please please please
tell us about this tell us where we can
get this where can everybody buy this to
support this because i know i didn't
even touch into a lot of stories because
i know this won't be the only time we
ever you're ever on the show we're going
to have to have you come back for sure
yeah yeah i love you short it's a
shorter episode i think that we would do
yeah i think there's going to be part
two three four
whatever we'll do something you can get
i have a book gangster redemption
actually helps you can get it on my
website you know how the book came about
dude i mean that came about when i did
the book i don't know 13 years
2013 or something like that 12 or 13.
and you know people wanted a i get
people wanted to buy it and i wouldn't
sell it so i own it i own this
[ __ ] right
but you know the book come about more
and more people are reading it saying
this is educational
kids should read and as a tough book to
be honest with you i was not a good guy
in the beginning you didn't want to
cross me it was a you'll read some stuff
but it also is a human story that
someone shouldn't be tortured and beaten
and everything else but it's a wild ride
but thank you it's a great book and they
can get it on our website and it's your
website uh what's our website i don't
know just
oh reality check program
realitycheckprogram.com
did you put your audible version of it
did i do what an audible no but no but
you know what people actually do
you know what people say i don't know
about that
they read it from from amazon
you can actually go amazon read gangster
redemption yeah but what if it was in
your voice
i'd pay five ten more dollars just to
get like this
larry's voice
yeah
i [ __ ] do
could you it's a podcast but they can
just read your book on their way to work
you should look into that because that's
something that you do once and you get
paid for the rest of your life exactly
forever
all you do is talk for three couple
hours
yeah sometimes i hate reading
i hate read my own [ __ ]
no no
i'm a big reader actually yeah well if
you think about it that's something i
would definitely
definitely love to listen to okay i'm
gonna do this throw it out there but
realitycheckprogram.com yeah there's a
great stuff there there's like you can
not only get the book you can get where
we do and help people the video and
stuff like that and that's the link
where you can watch it the one that you
said you can literally watch yeah yeah
and that's been award-winning since 2010
and and it's just so relevant because
it's about what could happen to you if
you keep [ __ ] up i've got a 13 year
old so we'll be oh absolutely i'll send
you the link obviously but that's it
yeah we'll put it in the description too
for everyone out there that wants to
check out the book or anything else it's
going to be in the description of this
video no matter where you're listening
all right i always have to say that
because people in the comments where can
i find it
just anyway that's it
i said at realitycheckprogram.com
thank you very much thank you so much
you had a great time you smoked it up
man
good [ __ ] man
thank you for coming oh i enjoyed it
this is how do you say the word oliva
they're my partner they're a great
company man it's gonna be called crooked
diamond my thing is coming out at the
end of here summit the crooked diamond
it's its own brand unbelievable i picked
it
that's gonna be fun man congratulations
i appreciate it i can see the excitement
every time you talk about it it's like a
little sparkle
diamond he hits that [ __ ] every time
yeah
man um where can everybody find you on
youtube it's just larry lot if you go
you go on youtube you just with larry
lawrence
yeah instagram same thing
instagram i think at real larry lawton
real long yeah okay well we'll put the
link in the description for everything i
appreciate that man you've been great
man i really am definitely kind of your
comment on mine 100 percent where are
you at i'm in florida so i'm going to my
partners are in florida i've still never
been so i need to go yeah you go and i
even have a rv i travel around so we
come down where you're at and we do it
if you're right
i have that 38 footer with [ __ ] two
bathrooms and all this [ __ ] oh you're
living it up over there no it's just
that i use that for you i'm saying
that's awesome anybody with an rv is
living in the [ __ ] up
for real but that's quite you've never
seen a guy not happy in an hour yeah
all right guys thank you so much i
appreciate it thank you so much guys
this has been the larry lawton episode
from marty larry and i appreciate it
have a dope day thank you guys thank you
very much thank you so much that was uh
that was fun man that was a funny that
was fun man thank you so much that was
good right yeah that was great this did
not make me feel bad you're welcome
i appreciate it well yeah marty please
yeah what do you feel or don't feel
distinguished no because you get a guest
if you want
yeah
[Music]